Hello, hello, I'm sorry I need a little bit more time I got
a little distracted oh my gosh um I had to fix some stuff uh
related to what's this above me oh that's new all right I
don't know what that is
Hey that's something that was broken I was trying to fix it
and I was like All right, all right, I had, okay, I'll
confess it was this above me.
That's what was broken.
I, um, it was like, it's like a Japanese program and I had
to recode this and it was all in Japanese.
So it took me an entire hour to recode this so I could
understand it in English.
So, so I was just like, and I realized, whoa, where did the
hour go?
I didn't even finish setting everything else up.
so i was like i was like snipping and google translating all
the japanese text because it was like they were using
japanese uh they were using japanese and their coding and i
was like what the fuck does this mean and i was like i have
to translate it and i have to recode it so i could
understand in english so i have to get this it is half
broken by the way um it was supposed to start at level one
but i don't know how to make it start at level one i i spent
an hour i was enough this is so i was just like i this is
good enough i start at low i we start at level three
whatever we'll start at level three fuck it it wouldn't let
me re reset my level i tried everything i don't i don't know
how i like fixed it i like okay originally all the text was
in japanese like you see to reach the next level exp and all
that that was all in japanese and I had to figure out where
the length where the text is so I can like convert it back
into English so I was like control f and I don't know I
don't even know I just like copied and pasted the characters
and I was just like and then like next next next exp next
exp next exp and then I realized nothing changed because
experience was in Japanese and I was just like I gotta
figure make that English so we all know what EXP is in
English and I realized I had to edit the website you the
website itself to make it at the opening notepad of the
website to edit EXP it wasn't in the coding it was in the
fucking website for some reason and so that that took me
like 30 minutes because I was just like it was like all in
Japanese like EXP and I was just like what the fuck is it
So, so I added all the coding where it said, like, it had
EXP in Japanese and it changed it to English, but it still
wouldn't change.
And I was like, oh, don't tell me it's the website.
Don't tell me it's the plugin itself.
So I, because I was like, I had to open the plugin via
Notepad.
And I was like, oh my God, it wasn't the plugin.
It wasn't the plugin document all along.
And that took me, that took like an hour.
The EXP portion alone took me in 30 minutes to figure out
because everything was in Japanese and
So this was why I was late.
I had to I had to re-edit this coding.
I had to learn how to use this So I found out about this
Japanese program where because like you guys might want all
these like So that's where I found out you know how I said I
want to do like the endurance super chat stream And I found
out like where it came from but But it all comes like
everything comes from this specific Japanese program Where
every like cool programming thing that the Japanese has done
For streaming is all linked to that one Japanese program So
I had to figure out how to it took me two to three out two
hours at most Two hours to like navigate the entire program
and I was like sniffing snip the snapshot tool snipping the
Japanese copy and pasting it into like Google Translate via
images and then trying to read every like because like
obviously that was like the only way I could translate the
program and so I was just like I had to do it like boop boop
boop and I found I found I realized and then I think like
one hour later while navigating this Japanese program where
where you can insert like coding and stuff for like
streaming I found out there was a tab in settings there was
like this extra tab all the way far right and it was
settings um it's called by the way it's called like why what
is it called what is this fucking site called it's called
one com um and I realized at the very end there was a
settings bar and I clicked on it and I did translate and
there was another separate settings bar and I looked at it
and I saw language And I was like, oh my god, this program
has English?
This program had English all along?
But after figuring out the program had English, I still had
to figure out the coding itself was not English, by the way.
So just like spot website.
does not have english so like one com is like it's like our
version is like the japanese version of ytc filter but like
much more efficient i will say because it shows all the
super chats all the memberships and then like every it has
an archive it also has an archive on comments itself and you
can it also has like a separate program in the program um
where you can uh where you can download templates and stuff
like coding templates that you put on there and then drag it
to the opia it's really cool um it's at it's really really
cool but like you have the entire website is in japanese
it's called one com the entire website is in japanese i
navigate it through google like through translate and i
doubt i assume i i automatically assume the entire program
is also in to get to navigate the website was like because
like on booth I noticed a lot of coding stuff uses one com
and I was like um and I was so I was like what is one com
because a lot of like really fancy coding that you can get
on booth uh where like a lot of youtubers get their like
backgrounds and everything and stuff was using one com
instead of like browser source on OBS and stuff instead of
like stream labs or everything they have their own basically
it's their own stream labs uh their own stream lab alerts
and everything So, so I was just like, why do they all use
one com?
What the fuck is it?
So then I realized I was just like, oh, sure.
It's like their own like YTC filter.
It's their own stream labs slash YTC filter because it has
everything.
So I downloaded because I was like, I want to use, I want to
use this EXP thing for this.
We'll find out what this is for very soon.
But I was just like, I want to use this because I think it's
going to be fun what we're going to be doing today.
And so, um, so I, obviously, I downloaded all that, but
yeah, the, uh, yeah, it's a Japanese streamer bot.
But basically, the, the coding stuff is all in Japanese.
And I mean, they have, like, obviously they have, like, you
know, coding is universal.
But then they, like, labeled stuff in Japanese.
So, because, like, it, like, they labeled some things in
Japanese, and I never took code, like, everything I learned
from coding is, like, me coding Neopets websites.
and so um so everything i know about coding is from me like
uh it's trial and error of me like learning how to code from
neopets and also like learning how to code websites and like
uh skin cosmetic skins and everything uh through deviant art
journals and like i all like everything i know about coding
is just trial and error like i i like just figured it out
for like just like just playing around with codes so um so i
was just like trial and erroring because i knew like the
japanese text because i needed to change the language of all
of this because like exp and to reach the new level exp all
that was in japanese so i had to figure out how to change
the labeling because the way they did it was that their
labeling thing was also like where to navigate was also all
in Japanese so I have to like fucking navigate and try to
figure out where exactly the labeling stuff is there's a lot
of issues with this right now it's like I it's like me
fucking getting scotch tape and um and taping everything
together uh because because I for the life of me I don't
know how to reset it to level one I tried everything we
start at level three I guess because like is a mode where i
could go ultra hard mode where i could start at level one
and because like the whole it goal was to get to level two
but at that point i i gave up i was just like i have i like
i was supposed to start at seven and it was like six uh 45
and i still was not finished setting everything up so i was
just like whatever we'll we'll just go with that like but
what makes the number go up.
It's up to you guys to figure it out.
Anyway, so I don't know.
I don't know how to because you can adjust settings where
you can make it ultra hard mode.
I don't know.
I don't know how to do it.
It's just, there is a way to make it go faster, go up
faster, but it's up to you to figure it out.
It's just how few.
Like, I already I spent two hours on coding guys.
I'm like it's I'm not even I didn't even code this myself I
spent two hours trying to figure out Japanese coding How to
understand Japanese coding and I was like this is good
enough
Zalpius thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you would be wow the website had English option
cheering on the new outfit from work Thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you to the number of goals between England and France.
You remembered that game, right Toki?
Oh, do I ever remember that game?
Hey, sir.
Thank you.
I was so mad.
so fucking mad about that game because you know i was just
like this game is trash this is awful i'm just gonna clock
it out after the four if they i was like if they shoot a
fourth goal we're calling it here and then they fucking shot
a fourth goal so i was just like all right this game was
like i it was so boring like yeah they were shooting goals
but it was so sad it was so fucking sad and then the moment
i left and boppe fucking scores three fucking goals and i
was just Like,
like, it turned into, like, the saddest game ever.
It's still Looney Tunes shit.
It was, like, it was still, like, fucking Looney Tunes,
whatever.
And, like, but it turned into, like, the fucking, the most
wild, wild-ass game ever.
I won't say it was, like, the best game.
They were just, like, shooting goals.
Like, yeah.
It's, it turned, it returned to the 100-year-old war
sequence.
But I missed the content.
I was so mad.
I literally lost I lost content It was be so funny to watch
with you guys.
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
Like it would have been so fucking funny to watch that game
like there was no defense Legitimately there was no defense.
They just went all in like
Like anything can happen and then it I did the fact that
they literally subbed in I feel like Jude was not even ready
to play he was just like wait i'm playing like yeah they had
like fucking a performance anxiety and everything yeah i was
just like i was just like what do you mean they scored four
fucking goals there was no defense it was just all offense
yeah it was the it was like it was just murder ball but like
with extra murder yeah i guess like imbappe just doesn't
perform well when i'm watching or something uh he gets shy
guys he gets like performance anxiety he knew i was watching
from my stream the fact that there was the first half there
was zero fouls like barely any fouls everybody was like hey
guys yeah and then the second half like fucking 80 fouls uh
a penalty kick and a half Um, people started yelling at each
other because they're faking fouls.
Like,
and, oh, if I did not have an alpha debut today, I would
have stuck it to the end.
I would, but like, I needed the time.
I was just like, you know, I, this was a bonus.
That was a bonus stream.
The watch line was a bonus stream anyway.
And the first half was absolutely terrible.
Like, not truly, truly nothing else is going to happen.
And it fucking, um, five, six, like what?
6 like what the fuck like um uh waste thank you the super
chat thank you thank you france went one if you didn't start
watching doki you're literally no no i was shooting for both
teams guys i as a as a fellow commonwealth and canadian um
we were raised by two by two dads we were raised by France
and England.
So, so there was no curse, guys.
Um, Jay LaCone, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
We Dragon is from DPS Bring You, uh, Bami Bromer Bird, a fan
game inspired by, oh, I saw that.
I wanted to look into that.
I don't know if we're going to see that today, or I'm going
to schedule it for a stream.
Thank you guys so much.
It looks so cool.
It looks amazing.
We posted a trailer on Twitter with a link to the Itchigo on
the 4th, but there was so much going on.
Thank you, another year.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you again.
It looks amazing.
I can't wait to check it out.
I was thinking of we should check out some birthday stuff
today as well after the outfit debut, but we'll see how I
feel after the debut.
Okay, to be fair, I don't really have much planned for the
outfit debut other than some stuff, the shit I spent two
hours on um trying to figure out above me
this shit above me right now other than that fuck see this
is why I pay people to code for me this is exactly I just
had to just copy and paste um oh level 11 I wonder what
happens when I hit a certain level what level it would be um
oh see thinking with super chat thank you thank you
technically you're double colonized by england via canada
and hong kong so shouldn't that be your favorite dad i don't
have favorites guys but some dads are a little bit more
favorite than other dads thinking about super chat thank you
thank you guys it's gonna take forever to get 69 You guys
don't even know what makes the XP bar go up yet.
I don't even think we're going to get to level 69.
Oh, yeah.
So, I will say.
I will have a merch drop when the outfit is revealed.
Letting you guys know right now.
It was supposed to be a birthday merch drop because it was
supposed to be linked towards.
Like I said, I was going to shadow drop the new.
That's why I had really originally had nothing to plan.
Because I was just like, oh yeah, I enjoyed the birthday
concert.
Bam, I also new outfit.
But I was so tired.
I was so fucking tired.
I, so, um, so like, uh, so the merch is technically birthday
and new outfits related to new outfit as well.
And, uh, just try everything, guys.
And, um, and there is a limited edition merch.
drop uh there is one the bundle one of the bundles is
limited edition because it includes a personalized uh
decorated sign checky um and there's only going to be 69 of
that so again thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you i need a new document thank you in the super chat thank
you thank you krish they give the five gift the ships they
can thank you so um so there's uh because i get to decide
how many i want to do and i want to do 69 of them because i
know you guys don't i don't give out a lot of autographs
like personalized autograph stuff because sometimes i just
don't have time and um those were one of the rare moments
that i i wanted to do something really special for um this
uh for the merch shop for i guess my birthday slash um uh ep
merch shop so this one rare moments where you can get
personalized what you want me to write on as well.
If you have any personal requests, like how you want me to
decorate or anything, there is going to be a box there that
you can write down what you want.
Quail, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, guys.
It might be the reaction bar on the right.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Joke, you're the only reason I'm going to tech on next
weekend.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
NetBirds, thank you for the super chat.
XP.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, having, oh, I always numbered them.
Don't worry.
Um, there was a Dragoon that got 69 and 67.
Um, at the Doki Doki Rewan concert.
Oh, yeah.
Predictions.
Um, I see a lot of you guys are curious or wondering what it
could.
I will say, though, this is my, this would be my favorite.
favorite uh outfit uh so far um i don't know about including
all the outfits i've had every single outfit i've had um
including like the chibi like for every skin suit i've had
not like concept ones not the con like concept ones and
everything actually yeah it would be my favorite out of all
of them um i don't want overhyped I'm, I'm giving you guys
so much, like, I'm, I'm, I'm giving you guys too much hype
now.
Uh, what is it called?
Um, over expectations.
I, is that the word?
This better be not being that guy.
How can I be trolling you guys?
That, it looks like a real silhouette this time, but where
is the belly button?
Gus, think of the super chat.
I think there, there may or may not be a belly button this
time, but also because, also I will say though, because like
i said there's so many things going on that um i had to
double like um my apologies to my papa cilia because she
obviously she gave me the skin suit stuff like uh at my on
my birthday and i didn't check it until yesterday and i was
like oops t he sorry
I was like, I'm so sorry.
Um, anyway, here are all my notes, but you do not have to
fix it for tomorrow.
Because there...
I had no, no, you'll understand.
You'll understand tomorrow.
Because there is a special announcement.
There is a...
There is a special announcement tomorrow, which will explain
everything.
So, I was like, I'm so sorry.
stuff going on but tomorrow tomorrow everything will be
explained because I was still very busy I was still very
very busy um after my birthday because I had a lot of other
stuff to do but tomorrow everything will be explained so um
there will be like um fixes to the skin suit um at another
time because there were like things that needed to be fixed
and things I wanted to change.
I know I should have checked I know I should have like
checked it out two weeks ago uh when she gave it to me but
yeah there are a lot of things look guys look there are a
lot of things I could have done differently that's it that's
it I'm not gonna elaborate more
it that's all i have to say that's all
oh yeah and also i played rivals too what's the last no two
days ago uh we don't want to show you guys this is the right
one i wanted to show you guys what the fuck where did i save
it well oh wait i didn't want to save okay this is from
frail bites animator now you might be wondering oh the frail
draw uh the frail draw prediction yes and no so this is what
frail thinks i look i'm gonna look like it's 10 p.m i forgot
to buy max for school tomorrow that basically that basically
solid thank you for the super chat thank you thank you but
you're a wizard dokey So, this was Frail's last-minute
prediction.
I will say a rope is involved.
Ted, thank you.
Thank you.
This one is from...
Oh, this one is cute.
This one is from Small Dragon Bun or Howell.
You might recognize her as well.
She is a frequent dragon artist.
But, oh, a dream fairy dokey.
I will...
Like, I wanted to include a rope because like I feel like um
you don't see a lot of robes in like pajama nightwear
outfits and I thought it would be a little unique thing I
mean I could take it off so it's not like glued to my skin
suit or anything but this is really cute I love the
nighttime um theme to it the stars the moon and everything
it's great also yeah so the pajama pajama outfit has been
something I've been wanting for wanting for a while um i
will say um it took us a long time we had three concept
artists to finalize the uh nightwear uh uh pajama outfit so
i went through uh my mama concepts concept did some stuff
and there were two other artists that conceptualized things
too so there was a A lot of brainstorming going on to make
IMO for me the perfect nighttime pajama outfit.
Because I was very picky about it.
I was very...
Was that the right word?
I guess picky is the right word, right?
Yeah, but thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
The moon sure is beautiful tonight.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Shiba, thank you for super chat.
chat thank you thank you testing continues you know super
chat thank you thank you yeah it was very particular um and
uh uh uh d uh picky about like what i want for a pajama like
in terms of like what i like i it's just i wanted the
perfect pajama that i would want to use all the time so
there was a lot of like scrap concepts in every thing this
one is from vermont or montfa and oh my god this is like
croaky theme but the with the croaky eye mask and then the
oh it's cute the tomatoes i love you and then the little
like a little uh little robe with the shark the sharky
slippers that one's cute i like it Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
And the boob.
The great thing about skin suits is that it's like...
Is she wearing a sports bra or not?
It's Schrodinger's boobs.
Schrodinger's boobs.
Will Doki have boobs or not?
But that's the great thing about skin suits and having a
sports bra on.
But yeah, also like...
I will say this skin suit...
is a lot the most feminine i'll i've been that's also why it
took so long to like draft up the perfect design because i
wanted like a balance between like girly but also like i
just wanted to be a bit more girly um than usual because i i
like wearing cute pajamas i don't just put on a t-shirt i
actually have pajamas pajamas Oh, there's this pajama I
bought recently when I was at Anime Expo.
What was it called?
I'm trying to remember the artist.
It was so cute.
I'm trying to remember who the artist was.
It was like, it was like sailor themed a little bit.
Anime Expo.
Artist Ali clothes.
Joki My bro, she's a girl.
Gross.
God.
Cooties.
My bro's a woman.
Fucking disgusting.
Oh my god.
Am I going to get cooties after watching her?
Ew.
All right, let me say I could find it.
Good girl.
But I do have, I do buy pajamas.
I don't just wear a t-shirt and then call it a day.
I don't know.
I just like comfy pajamas.
Well, I can show you this one.
This one I have.
I can't find...
I have funny.
Okay, Anime Expo Catalog.
Maybe.
I need to look at the website.
Oh, I look at Exhibitors List.
Maybe I can find it here.
Oh, wait.
I don't know how to find it.
Guys, I need to show you guys this.
It's okay.
I have plenty of time until my XP bar goes up.
up.
You guys still haven't figured out how to make it go up, so
I have plenty of time.
I'll never tell you guys how to figure out yourself.
Just want me to hand out.
You want to just want me to, I want a handout or something.
Affiliate, I'm thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Jason, thank you for ten gift of ships.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to find I'm trying to find the pajamas bot.
This is very important.
It's very, very important, guys.
What's up?
Let me out look at apparel.
Nope.
Not this one.
Is it her?
I'm just going to look at apparel.
That would help me.
I'm going to look at apparel and this one.
try and find guys don't it's gonna be so worth it you're
gonna see the pajama and you're gonna be like worth it it's
really really cute i'm not over hyping it guys i'm not
setting up your expectations really high i swear to god
you're gonna be like oh my god i can't believe i waited an
hour for Doki to find her pajamas.
Like, Vod Watchers, please go to one hour and 30 minutes.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is my clothes?
Go faster, chat.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, What's it this
one?
No, it's not this one.
Where the fuck is it?
Okay.
Maybe it's...
No, it's not Mega 64.
This is this one?
No, I know it's definitely not Omino because I know their...
I know their clothes.
Oh, is it?
No.
No, it's definitely not that.
Alright, I'm checking the websites.
What the fuck is that website?
What?
Wait, those jackets are sick.
You can't even see what I'm looking at.
I'm sure the artist will make the outfit worth the way.
Yeah, man.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, guys.
Guys, I swear to God.
It's so worth it.
It's so cute.
Fine.
I'll show you guys this other pajama I own.
I sure you know.
No, I have to.
Wait, give me a sec.
I'll be right.
back i have to show it to you guys give me a sec i'll be
right back i swear it's so worth it guys it's so fucking
worth it guys
i found it all right i found the shop i told you guys it's
so worth it all right it's called time poppo
all right uh
pajamas It's not up on the shop Wait a minute wait a minute.
Did he not have it up on the shop?
But I was gonna show my chat how worth it it is
I was gonna show my chat how worth it
Oh Gina knew Gina why weren't you here earlier?
Wait, I swear to God Did it have it on Twitter?
Guys, I need to show you how worth it
Oh my god, it's not even in on Twitter It's not even on
Guys, I swear it was so worth it
Wait, wait, wait Tempo Po House pajamas
maybe I can google image it oh my god their pajamas isn't
even I can't even okay just think about how how worth just
like visualize it in your head it was worth it
just just visualize it guys visualize the cutest best
pajamas you've ever seen and that was it and it was worth it
It was, but this is the shop.
They have really cute, I bought a lot of cute stuff from
them.
It's the pajama in the room.
It was, I do, I have it.
It's just, it's just in the laundry right now.
That's a lie.
It's in my suitcase and I haven't unpacked yet.
It's in my suitcase.
The pajamas Were, I was like That I believe Thank you, Super
Chat, thank you, thank you Um Thank you, Super Chat, thank
you, thank you Gina, oh my god you Super Chat And after I
left, too Gina Thank you for the same chat, thank you, thank
you Thank you, um Alright, okay, anyway, next Outfit
Prediction Um, is that the last, oh wait, this one This one
is from Agito.
You might recognize this from a very controversial manga,
apparently.
But this was Agito's...
Agito's design prediction.
I don't know what's...
Okay, so apparently it's based off of that really
controversial cat manga, Because it's like really grossed
out humor or something.
I don't know.
I've never like watched.
I don't just know it because apparently People in Japan were
trying to get the The manga cut cancelled or get the manga
cancelled and everything and then like and but then like he
kept he kept on Drawing and writing it and then now there's
an anime adaptation.
They're trying to get it cancelled again Yeah, it's a it's
the chain smoker cat.
Yeah, so like what's wrong with it?
I haven't read it so i don't know what's wrong with the
chain smoker cat is it because she smokes but don't people
but like um people smoke in japan like it's because it's a
smoking cat like cobalt thank you for the 10 gift of ships
thank you thank you oh it's disgusting okay but like what
makes it disgusting though it's just gross it's gross out
it's just gross out uh manga Gross, is it like that new
anime that Netflix is promoting right now with the, the, the
drugged, uh, the girls or some shit?
Paturista, thank you for the super.
Oh, whoa.
Oh.
I see.
Paturista, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
I see.
Also, it's like that other anime that's.
That's coming out.
The one with the two girls.
Like, doing drugs.
Why?
Thank you, Superchild.
Thank you.
Wait, so, like, what's wrong?
Okay, but I felt like I heard saw more people complaining
about the cat.
The cat show.
More than the other one.
The other one from Netflix.
Is it because this one has a cat in it?
Is it because of that?
Does he have a cat?
The cat show is on?
I guess, yeah, because the Netflix one isn't out yet.
I assume that.
Yo, should they give a super chat?
Thank you.
Have you ever been in a chain smoker's apartment?
I did.
It's gross.
Think of a super chat?
Thank you.
My dad's a smoker.
So, I think my lungs are a bit fucked up from secondhand
smoking.
So, I mean, my dad's a smoker.
uh rice thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's an unglamorous look at addiction self-destructed living
and people are made that's not that that's not just kawaii
anime kakura wait and you compare me to her wait a minute
what am i compared to her am i a bad role model guys no no
it can't be i can't be a bad role model my taxes.
Gee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I say it's because it's just too gross.
It's kind of everyday grossness.
It's just too close to real life.
Oh yeah, because you watch it to escape.
I'm going to the super chat.
Thank you.
Fudge top.
I'll be honest.
I thought you were the landlady from Kung Fu Hustle.
Thank you.
I thought so too until I saw the cat ears.
Because the cat ears like reminded me of the cat show.
Um.
I do in fact, it do in...
Okay, Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't get it twisted.
She's cute, but disgusting at the same time.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Stairs in...
Guys, there's no more mold in my sink anymore.
See?
I'm improving.
There hasn't been in a while.
Like, maybe like...
months maybe and that's it thank you for the raid thank you
thank you all right guys if we can hit level 21 maybe
something special will happen uh gordon thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you uh counterpoint hambo lector
also paid cat taxes yeah and he an upstanding citizen.
Maybe something will happen at level 21.
Maxi.
Yeah, but he's also like, he was a doctor.
Wait, was he?
Yeah, he was a doctor.
Maxi, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Doctors save lives.
People trying to cancel just aren't used to gross and very
real substance abuse portrayals.
Mainstream anime audience don't like anti-escapism.
Thank you.
Super chat.
chat thank you thank you if you pay your taxes why did my
deliver driver go on strike the play foot oh thank you super
chat thank you thank you um that i think it was super chat
thank you thank you just god knows that every single match
is shipping hype for it yay now you can buy the birthday
merch later too it's a cycle it's a never-ending cycle thank
you super chat thank you thank you all right what about
level 22 oh oh my god we hit level 22 21!
The XP bar can legally drink in America now!
Let's go!
And to reward you, you now have a chance to get to level 22!
See, I chose a number.
I chose a special number for when for when the event starts.
So we haven't hit it yet because the thing hasn't
automatically played.
So,
at least it's getting faster, you know?
At least it was not worth it.
Guys, look, it's going fast.
My XP bar is leveling up even faster now.
NSD, thank you, thank you.
I love this episode of TreeCurebird.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Nephirs, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I think it's a government-funded anti-drug PSA campaign.
And you must super chat that we are in Tokyo.
We are not hitting 69.
Guys, why do you think it's 69, guys?
Come on.
Wait, actually, is that this is the right number?
Let me check real quick.
Okay.
Okay, I might have miscounted, guys.
It was actually level 21.
I let's say level 22.
Sorry, I, like, cancelled.
I cancelled the level up.
Yeah!
Level 22!
What do you mean?
I miscounted, guys.
Everything, you under, everything, um...
Won't make sense.
Why isn't it working?
Hello?
Oh!
Hey!
Hello.
Let's go!
Your dokeymon gained EXP points.
Yeah!
I told you guys!
I told you!
It works!
Brokeybird grew to level.
Level 2!
Yay!
See, this is when I was trying to get it.
I was trying to reset it to level 1, but it didn't work,
guys.
So then, I didn't have time to edit.
I didn't have time to fix it.
So, level 2.
Yay!
I said, I...
Level 2!
It's like...
We forgot the 2, guys.
We forgot the 2!
Yay!
Nice.
Oh, sweet.
I got more attack.
Nice.
All right.
Brokeybird is trying to learn the move.
See, I told you.
Everything will make sense.
Brokeybird is trying to learn the move math.
I don't think I need that.
it's fine.
But Brokeybird can learn more than four moves.
Yep.
Should another move be forgotten and replaced with math?
No.
I don't think we need that, guys.
I have... No.
Yeah, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Am I really, really sure?
Yeah, I'm sure.
Brokeybird will... Oh, shit!
I get to learn a second move!
Let's fucking go!
Once to learn the move, sleeping Oh, yeah, I've been waiting
for that one, guys.
I...
I've been waiting to learn that move for a while.
Damn, right, we're going to learn that one.
That one's important.
My Brokeybird cat learned more than four moves.
All right, it's time to forget a move, guys.
Should another be moved?
Yes.
All right, we have Paying Taxes, Marble Rivals, Dragoon
Chuck.
Or confusion.
I, you know, I feel like all of these moves are all equally
as important as each other.
Can we forget paying tax?
I know, I feel like that, you know, I do love not committing
tax fraud.
But I also love sleeping in.
So it's really hard to pick between the two.
But I feel like sleeping in will...
uh will pay off on itself you know just like not paying
taxes i just like paying taxes just like
so i'll forget that i think that's good poof all right nice
broky bird forgot paying taxes and broky bird learned
sleeping in yeah
i think it was a good exchange guys
I think Is that it?
Am I just going to learn new moves?
Nothing else?
What
the fuck?
I'm so tiny.
Press B.
What do you mean, press B?
From my It's so tiny.
Wait a minute.
Bro become...
Well, um, now I'm EP Brokey Brain.
Well, anyway, outfit reveal.
No, I'm joking.
I'm sure there's...
There is!
There is an outfit reveal.
I guess...
I guess that wasn't the level I was supposed to level up on.
I was supposed to evolve on, guys.
I'm looking pretty.
Epee.
I am.
I am pretty Epee.
I've been working a lot, guys.
I am pretty Epee right now.
That's press.
That's your fault for pressing B.
Now my growth is stunted.
I'll never hit puberty now.
Peach who has evolved into Peach who.
Alright, who's got the rare candy, guys?
I think this isn't the level I'm supposed to evolve.
I've only I'm only peach you has evolved to Pikachu.
I guess it's my final evolution Now now you'll never learn
thunderbolt We gotta reach level 44 till we get to level 3
Do we need a trade with so is she a trading evolution?
Is she like Gengar quick?
Who has the who has the DS slash game boy?
Should we leave her in the quick leave her in the daycare.
We'll come back for her.
We'll take time travel.
Toki, do you need an AP stone?
Toki.
Dragons, how are you supposed to get IVs up like this?
Fuzzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who has a link cable?
We need a link cable.
Is it item evolution?
What is it?
Well, I have one... There is a win... There is a win
condition for me to level up.
But it's up to you to figure out what it is you don't know
that there's only one there's only one dokey bird in the
wild a secret third option quick everyone turn your monitors
upside down forward thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you there is a there is a special condition to get me
to to evolve It's up to you to figure out what it is.
God damn it, my Doki Bird isn't a shiny.
I guess we have to restart the run.
Well, I guess I have to end the stream so we can restart the
stream until we got a shiny Doki Bird.
Maxi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The CRA used tax on EP Brokey Bird.
It's super effective.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Broken Bond.
thank you for the super chat thing thank you god damn it
dokey had the raw nature time to start over again diet thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you rice
thank you for the super chat thing thank you so we put the
thunderstone where did you not see my type do you not see my
my type advantages guys why would i need a thunderstone when
i'm a flying dragon type
Thor type?
Quick, look under the truck.
Take her to the truck.
Pokemon, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Surely we can just Dynamax her to make her regular size
Tokyo.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Osteen, thank you for the Super Chat.
Checking the pickup truck right now.
You need a Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta.
Super Quail.
Thank you.
Is this the win?
Do I look like I'm evolving
Guess I'll be stuck I'll be stuck as a baby forever Um
Savior thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you
Dokey I'm a dinner Can we try Thank you for the super chat
Thank you thank you Uh, crazy.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
I'm like the cast coon or cast form.
Uh, you put me in an environment and I just changed form.
I didn't even level up.
I just changed my form.
Now I'm, now I have my form is sleepy and poison.
Airborne ninja.
All right.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Who's level 12?
Get the butcher knife.
This one's a done.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
The moment you figure out what my win con is, You're gonna
feel so stupid, guys.
You're gonna feel so silly when you...
When you figure out what it is, you're gonna feel so fucking
silly because no one has done it.
No one has done the WinCon, the My Specific Evolution type
yet.
But I tried so...
Did you, though?
Did you?
You're on the right track.
That's all I'll say.
It's the hearts, isn't it?
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What about this one?
Wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The WinCon is really, literally missing no, guys.
We're screwed.
An actual Dimitrodon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pretty sure.
Alone, Dokey Bird has different evolution conditions.
super chat thank you thank you guys guys guys I have
literally one win condition in my if you read the jokey
birds manual guide you would see you see that at it's not
that at a certain point when I level up to when I evolve to
EP brokey bird the only way to get me to my next evolution
is only one thing there's only it's very easy just think
real nice and hard about it look at the colors do the colors
tell you anything oh it's the friendship level look at the
colors what do
Mina, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
The buyer merch.
The colors!
J.L.Col, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Who got that R99 stone?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I don't...
I don't know what to do.
The color is even mean.
It must be the...
If we...
Don't be afraid of you...
If you open this store, we can buy more dogsters so we can
evolve you.
We got to get to level 67.
Okay, maybe there's two win conditions.
This was so weird.
What do you figure when you find out...
When you find out what the wind condition...
Well, it was originally something else.
But then I'm like, well, we're not getting there, obviously.
So...
I'm losing my mind.
Nah, knockup.
But here's Medi's blood-ass sacrifice.
I hope that's enough punch.
Alright.
Alright, there's...
Alright, guys.
There's three wind conditions now.
Now there's three.
I've hacked the game.
I've hacked the game and changed the coding for Eepie Brokey
Bird.
So we can get the second win.
The third win condition.
Guys, let's just wait to level.
Guys, I did thought I would.
Look, if I could code better, maybe the levels will go
faster.
Unfortunately, I don't know how to fix it.
it.
It still says it's level six on the coding page.
So, like, I don't know.
This is the best I could do.
It's I don't know.
Alright, alright, alright.
We're almost there.
Guys.
You're all what if we throw tomatoes at Doki?
Crazy.
They give a super chat thingy thingy.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, what did the Twitch chat say?
I didn't even...
I forgot I had Twitch chat on.
You sound very...
It was originally level 69.
Okay, I will say.
Originally, it was...
Whoa!
Why did it go down?
Why are we devolving?
Guys!
Guys, why are we devolving?
Why?
I'm... I'm devolving!
Why am I...
Why am I going down?
Ah!
No, what's going on?
I'm losing XP!
Oh my god.
I'm still...
Evolution in the reverse right now.
It's going down!
So...
And then...
Take her back to level one.
Get her!
We're resetting.
This is not the...
This is not...
She doesn't have the right Eevees, Ivies.
I'm getting this level three.
Reach quitting this Dokiman game.
And going back to Digimon time.
Stranger or powered.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding!
Donkey bear monsters, Donkey-Bomb are the tank-ups.
Donkey-Bomb, Donkey Bear monsters, Donkey-Bomb are the
tank-ups.
Eepy, Brokey, Donkey-Bomb, too.
Donkey-Bomb into ultimate.
Merger the Eepy, Donkey-Bomb.
Ah.
The tank-Bomb.
Guys, I told you.
I told you it was easy
I I I told you it was being there was a wind condition all
in there what are you easy.
It was Doki-mon this entire time.
Oh my god.
I told you.
The wind condition was easy.
She broke the go-go so hard.
She did evolve.
I told you guys.
I don't know why you guys couldn't figure it out it took us
40 minutes and cost us thousands it was easy i gave you a
hint i i gave you a hint can you move the feet up a little
up to the left whoa whoa whoa oh my dokey bombs uh shout out
to song in two days.
Doki Man, Doki Bird Monsters, Doki Bird is the champion.
It's the, alright.
Well, let me slowly, well, we saw, like, majority of this.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I just realized.
Let me forgot to put on.
Boop.
Is that the stream?
Is that the manual?
I don't know.
So here's my robe.
I can take it on and off, but also.
Bam!
Look at that.
It changes color depending on...
It's like light mode or dark mode.
You know, if I want to read something in the dark, I turn on
dark mode.
You know?
We'll go in dark mode right now because it is night time.
So, but yes, there's a little dragon slippers right here.
And then my little robe, my little dangly, dangly robe.
I'm a wizard.
I am.
Wow.
The light and dark mode, you know, battery save mode.
Exactly.
Wow.
Fortunately for me, the slippers do not come up.
And I say as I see thousands of viewers start leaving now.
Um, but yes.
There's like the thing I tie my robe on.
Bada, bada, bada, bump, bump, bump, champion.
Doki Mim, Doki Bird Monsters.
Doki Bird are the champions.
Bum, bada, bada, bada, bada, bum, bada, bum, bada, bump,
bump, bum.
And then We're slowly Slowly I'm wearing little short shorts
A little short comfy shorts So you guys look, look, see?
Look, look Do you see it?
Do you see it?
I do, I do have a belly button Yes, I do Yes, it's It's
right here.
You can see it.
Look, it exists.
It actually exists.
So, that was one of the hot fixes that Celia did.
Because originally, the belly button was like up in my
lungs.
No, not in my lungs.
It was like up where my...
How to explain it.
Yeah, it's like near my lungs.
So we had to like...
Push it down a little bit.
We had to do a little plastic surgery.
We had to do...
At one point, I thought, like, I didn't even have a belly
button.
Because I remember kept asking my mama and being like, can I
have a belly button?
And then I think I asked them, like, five times during the
process.
And I was so confused.
Because I was like, where is belly button?
Where is it?
And I asked Celia, I was like, do you know where my belly
button is?
And she was like, oh yeah, it's like all the way up, like,
all the way up there where my arm is, where my hand is right
now.
So she's like, I can, I can like surgically push it down a
little bit more.
I can, I can push it down a little.
yesterday um uh so we know i'm not a clone i'm not clone
baby i'm not test tube baby i have a belly button so so just
a little you know because glad i'm it's good to know that
i'm not test tube baby you know there's little things in
life knowing that so where's my um okay so let me go up a
little bit oh yes this is another thing like this
It's dead!
Look at him!
He's also Eepy.
Look at this Eepy boy.
He's so sleepy.
I still cannot believe I triggered Doki's digital pollution.
I thought of Digimon since Doki is a digital being.
Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that!
You got the wind condition.
look at that all right dude okay the original win condition
was Digimon but I was like I don't know of any but okay the
original win condition was level 69 but I don't think we
were getting there I could not fix the coding I don't know
how to fix it um I didn't know how to fix it I gave up So
that was the original win condition to get to, to get there.
And then the second one was for someone to say, did you
mind?
What did you, Bob?
You had to say, did you mind?
So that was the second win condition.
And the third one that thought maybe someone would do, maybe
like it might have been the easiest.
So I was just like, whatever, Akasupa.
Like, that was the third one that I added as, like, a last
minute.
I'll be like, maybe someone at Akasupa.
And then I'll just trigger it.
Because I don't know if anybody's going to say Digimon.
So, those were the three win conditions to get the Doki
Volution.
dokey buff too um but yes look i can also look at this yeah
also another one another um um fix that we're doing is i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get nail polish i forgot uh to put on
nail polish today guys i'm sorry i i already used a nail
polish remover last night and i forgot I had to take it off
for the for the health of my nails I took off my I took off
my clip on nails so um so I forgot to put on some new nails
on but it's bear right and I know I know I'm so scandalous
guys oh my gosh my raw nails stop shaking them shake the
baby
It's a slumber party.
Oh, that's why.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why.
Guys, I didn't put any nail polish on because I forgot
today's a slumber party.
We're so busy digivolving.
I forgot we were doing a slumber party.
But don't you guys know?
We're supposed to put nail polish on each other during the
slumber party.
That's why I took my nails.
I guess why I removed my nails.
Oh, not my nails.
Sorry.
I removed my nail polish.
So we could put, we should paint our nails, guys.
You know, average sleepover activities.
We paint each other's nails.
Sleeping or what the fuck are you talking about?
Oh, yeah.
I also have a little hat, too.
Um, other than dad, um, I also have a little dragon.
Cool.
dragon on here.
Wait.
D-Clock, dude.
Hello.
Look, it's you guys.
That's you.
Look.
It's you.
But yes, I can also take off my robe too.
I also hold you guys here.
And also hold dad like this.
I think I like it.
And then, look.
Oh my god, he's so cute.
Look at him.
You're so eepy.
Look at him go.
Yeah, oh, scandalous.
She's showing so much skin.
Harlot!
Burn her!
Look at all the skin she's showing.
burn hair then I think it was super chat thank you thank you
this is a real and then you pad to the face the face is
what's not shown right now and then it's sexy dokey god I
wish but also I not only have short hair but I also have
long hair but I think the short hair is cuter so I'm going
to keep I'm going to show his short hair yeah so I'll put my
road back on um no please well well we'll know when we see
the face if it's if it's sexy doky or not uh youtube versus
twitch pillow fight war i saw that i forgot twitch chat on
all right you're gone twitch chat i'm sorry
whoa whoa do you see that do you see that guys all right let
me get that out of the way all right oh we're almost there
whoa yo the length of your neck is insane oh you're right i
know what you're to do where is it all right i have more
time oh i i get to i get to edge a little longer i guess
well i wonder what's up there i wonder thanks for reminding
me shout out to who was it Who was it?
Shout out to...
Remember, you gotta thank that guy.
Shout out to Fudge Top.
Your boy Fudge Top.
We're dragging it out a little longer.
Whoa.
That log is how's the weather up there.
Pretty nice.
Not gonna lie.
I read the loading for him all along.
goodness it's not as cursed like the swimsuit mod i'm still
traumatized by that reveal um hsp thank you the super chat
thank you thank you all right but you see a little bit of
the scrunchy here too oh you see a little bit of the eyes as
well someone did give a branch to me so i just start eating
later i was like um Um, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Uh, we're almost there, guys.
You might need to have a stool to stand on to see the rest.
Go, Toki, get down here.
She has eyes, guys.
She has a mouth.
She has eyes.
It's not sexy, Toki.
What is this paralysis, Steven?
Okay, okay, wait.
Let me...
All right, all right, all right We're ready, guys I, like I
said, this This is my favorite outfit So far Because I think
it's really Really, really cute And you'll see why Oh yeah,
before I do reveal it There's also Uh Let me see.
Light mode!
Ah!
Alright.
Nya!
Am I cute?
I know I look so cute.
oh my gosh but look at me without the hat though about the
hat yeah my what's it called I don't want to say it wrong
the hair is flask
that's why I have a hat to cover it don't you why did you
have to ruin the mode that's so cute guys look how cute I am
yeah my eyes are so bright let me oh wait wait this is one
of my favorite parts too so not only do I have but like yeah
I have the light mode I think dark mode is prettier but um
my favorite oh and then here's me with a long hair and But
also, I have Most forgot And look, now we're matching For
those who own the The tomato sleep mask Now we're matching
too Oh, I almost forgot This was my favorite part
Tokeybon Tokeybon
I think like I got inspired um
I got inspired by I think I I saw mint had one of those that
um pre-drawn poses and I saw her doing this pose I was like
oh I would want something like that too And I was like...
I think this one was my favorite part About my new skin
suit.
I don't know, it looks so cute.
Oh my god, but then like, neuron activate.
Watch this.
Neuron activate it.
I think the glasses...
The glasses work so, so well with this outfit.
Like, I think it works really well with the new skin suit.
And also, like, I don't know, it just, it's just with the
hair and the skin suit, too.
Oh, I don't know what I think you hear this.
I can read now.
Oh, my God, I can't pay my taxes.
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
I don't know if you're, if it's like, it's weird that
Dokiman is playing the background while I'm doing this.
Am I?
Don't keep mine.
Don't keep your monsters while I'm doing this.
Guys, it sets the mood, okay?
It's the immersion, guys.
We're jamming it out at the slumber.
party but yes here is um it's part of the show tokymon
tokymon monsters the champion
yeah it's the perfect balance oh my god the glasses are
fogging up but um but yeah and then there's dad It's okay.
He's just sleeping.
He's in a really deep sleep.
He's alive.
Long hair and glasses.
Day chat magic.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I think the glasses work better with the short hair.
I was like testing it out.
Testing out all the combinations and stuff.
But yeah!
Now you see why this has been my favorite.
This has been my favorite outfit so far.
Pickle cucumber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will you be in my sleep paralysis demon.
Yeah, now you know.
Now you know why this is my favorite at the moment.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's go to my room now.
Yay!
Okay, you won.
Long hair and... Oh, hey.
Twitch chat's back.
Yoink.
Never mind.
Snap.
You're gone.
All right, long hair and glasses.
It looks like this.
And my dad here, he's just chilling.
You want me to have the hat on?
Hat or no hat?
Let's see.
How do I turn it off?
There you go.
This is no hat.
I like the short hair more.
I think the short hairs, I like it more.
But I think it's so cute.
I love how it all turned out too.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, and there's mine.
There's I was joking just that Digi-Bobbing.
Not only did I Poke-Bob, I also Digi-Bob.
Oh yes, there are lo-fi too.
um wait let's see sorry i need to get catch up to the super
chats uh great thank you for super chat thank you thank you
i just enjoyed what i was doing oh i just read that uh ak
thank you super chat thank you thank you super cute outfit
dokey so many powerful combos we are holy i know there's so
many combinations i told you guys i was supposed to debut
this outfit um i think it was supposed to be debuted two
months ago um but cilia had a uh medical issue and i was
like it's all right uh just take your time and then i was
like oh i could do it for my birthday so then we rescheduled
it for my birthday um so i'm happy to finally be able to uh
debut um my new outfit um and i know i think like i said
this is my favorite also shout out to chow for help like uh
chow um does majority of the uh the cut that does the
cutting and also helped add some extra stuff uh to the skin
suit that was missing so shout out to chow chow cherry and
cilia because you're like a team i think they do it for all
the sloppy sisters too uh cindy thank you super chat thank
you um i cute a sucker for women pajamas i prefer long hair
but short hair is good too i think i think my favorite is
currently the short hair version i think it's i don't know
the little the little buttons and everything i like the so
the little tiniere wings my wings clipped um i had to get a
haircut and then the you know because it's sleepy time so
it's like light a little bit lighter too because i got my
hair clipped there got a little haircut so the color is
growing back in and i don't know if i like hat or no hat
tiny little wings you like the hat or no hat more
their fetters unless don't unless don't don't cut like too
deep into the fetters because you can you can clip wings
without hurting uh without hurting the bird uh i finally i'm
thank you for the five gift dishes thank you thank you i
didn't both look good i'm my manliest dude can't be this
cute oh my god jean thank you thank you thank you all right
i'm gonna take you through the design process like i said um
i think it took like two to three months to settle on the
design because um i had a really hard time trying to figure
out what i want um so it took me uh a really long time to
sell it because at first the pajama was very boyish it was
very tom boyish but i wanted something um only mg i will
only do it for jesus
haster thank you for the aqua i know i won't go to hell if
jesus asks for it uh thank you for the aqua soup uh haster
thank you thank you yeah but he didn't ask for the combo uh
thank you for the aqua soup thank you thank you son thank
you for the five gift of ships thank you thank you yeah but
he didn't ask for the he didn't ask for the combo uh Yeah.
Jesus, where are you?
And we need you the most, Jesus.
Quick, someone pray to Jesus right now.
Okay, so, what was I going to say?
All right, so I'll show you guys the design process.
My middle name is Jesus.
Is that you're going to make me pay for Jesus?
Thank you.
Ah, maybe I am going to hell.
Doki, in the Bible, you're not supposed to tempt it, Jesus.
No!
Husky, thank you for the Akasuke.
Thank you, thank you.
It's time to...
He has risen.
And on the third day, he rise.
Jesus has returned.
Hallelujah.
All right, all right.
We'll do it during the...
green screen but i'll talk tell you guys about um the
process so you don't remember when i said i had three
designers um for this outfit so uh so the main designer that
we settled on is all right i need to well i need to adjust
this uh but but but but here all right so you might
recognize this art style and it's from Maddie I always love
Maddie's design work and art she is a very very talented
artist you might recognize her art she does a lot of design
stuff for snuffy and I always love I know she's just really
really good at sleepwear so she was the last person I
recruited to help me this design um the sleepwear because
like I was just trying to figure out like like what to do
because I wanted something girly yeah so uh she is snuffie's
uh designer she has designed a lot of stuff for snuffie and
I've always loved her like she has designed a lot of like
her specialty I feel like it's just sleepwear like um like
she's just so good at doing sleepwear and I like she I knew
she would be able to get the vision I wanted because I
wanted something a little girlier because i know like a lot
of my other outfits they're very boyish very tomboyish but i
wanted something different i wanted a little um something
new for this one so this is my fourth outfit i wanted
something new and i wanted something more girly more
feminine and she knocked it out of the park oh my gosh it's
so cute um but anyway so um at first i was like thinking
about like maybe
iteration um before uh i asked maddie if she could help me
um and this was from my mama um and you guys can see it was
very boyish and um because i was like oh like because i
wanted sleep whip i didn't know exactly what i wanted at
first so as you guys can see it was a a very boyish design
and i was just like what do i is that what i is that what i
want like um so so it was like you know regular pajamas uh
beans out a little like a jacket um and that's my bro that's
what i'm talking about yeah it was very cute but i still
wanted something more feminine because i have a lot of very
uh boyish outfits so i wanted you know i wanted something
different something more relaxing because i do have a lot of
very cute pajamas i wear pajamas and we're a lot of really
cute pajamas very feminine pajamas so i wanted something
like that so i was like maybe it's the colors maybe we could
change the colors and then so we were playing around with
like pastel colors as you can see oh my gosh i can't even
like well i'm trying to like figure out where we're the
we're okay here we go yeah i'll be here i'll be like leaning
over it um so we went we tried to do like uh maybe it was
the colors so i played around with a bunch of color theme
like a bunch of color palettes with my mama and uh so as you
can see i was like oh maybe purple maybe pastel yellow maybe
play around with all these different pastel colors but i
still wasn't happy but i also wanted a nightcap because i
was like um because we wore a nightcap that one time oh
you're right you're so right shout out to that one guy that
told me to do this wait wait that works show up to my boy
tell me to do that all right this works okay so anyway um
hey if it works it works Um...
Wait, I can't...
Oh my god.
Wait, where is it?
Where did I put the image?
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Yeah, alright, there we go.
Alright, anyway.
It's actually so useful.
You're right, it's so useful.
Finally, it has actual functionality other than edging and
baiting you guys.
It's like a puppet show.
Yeah!
It's like...
Oh?
Oh, oh, whoa, peekaboo, peekaboo, peekaboo, peekaboo, all
right, so as you guys can see, um, I was like, maybe it's
just the colors, because I do like the jacket, but I was
thinking, um, but yes, the nightcap inspiration, uh, came
from, you know, during one of the good night dragons where I
wore a nightcap, and I was just like, oh, I really, I think
that's really cute.
I think I'm gonna I'm gonna keep that.
Oh, yeah, wait.
Give me a sec.
I just realized.
Well, sleepy time.
Sleepy time.
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo.
Oh, because I should be using this.
Sorry, I was using the wrong one.
So, um, but anyway.
Um, uh, so we went with that and then...
Let's see.
And then I was like, I want to be sexy and cute.
I don't want to be like just cute.
I want to be sexy too.
Like sexy dokey.
But nobody can be as sexy as her though.
I will admit.
No one can be as sexy as sexy dokey.
So, um, um, so I asked about that.
And then my mama.
shit my mom whoop now i can lower my neck now my mom came
with a black and white design um that was sexy but then i
was like but then now it wasn't sexy and cute it was just
sexy so i was just like well i want to have a balance
between the two uh yeah i know it was a jump between the
other i I know.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, that might be too sexy.
That.
So I was like, I wanted like, um, um, is there sportswear
under that nightgown?
Yeah, I'm wearing a sports bra under this nightgown.
Mr. McFluff begins taking the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, uh, so I, because I also wanted cute as well so um i
didn't go with this one because like i said it was uh it was
too sexy so uh then i recruited gina uh next to you thank
you thank you thank you so gina draws uh also i recruited
her and she helped with coming up with the innerwear of the
the sleepwear uh of the pajama outfit so Orca colored.
I see Orca.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Rodrigo.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Sexy and cute.
She, if you look beautiful now, you can do this.
I don't know if I can do that lap.
All right.
I got... All right.
There you go.
Sorry.
I need to be taller.
So, these are Gina's concept artwork.
So, I gave her the same prompt.
I'm looking for sexy and cute.
So she came up with some design concepts.
You can see that, you know, there is some...
Well, not there, but let me get Dad out of the way.
I think this was...
Well, that's not Dad.
Let me get Dad out of the way real quick.
I need to, like, reorganize my stream deck, by the way.
Alright.
So, you see, like, some elements from Gina's made it in
here.
Because, like I said, it was a group effort.
uh with everybody so um oh yeah i forgot to show you guys
this sorry sorry about the long neck but i also have a
controller it also works by the way well i have to be long
right now so i can show you guys the concept all right so
this is gina's uh design concepts and then i was like what
if i really want a row So, another thing that I really
wanted to implement is a robe, because, like I said, I don't
see a lot of sleepwear with robes on.
I always see a lot of, like, jackets, sweaters, just the
loungewear, but no robe.
I've noticed that, especially for, like, you know, for,
like, female V-tubers outfit reveals with nighttime.
I never see a robe.
So, I thought, you know, robes are nice and comfy, and
they're, like, very...
I don't know.
Was it posh is the white right word?
Like very stylish.
Uh, uh, and everything.
So I really wanted a robe to fit in there.
Not just like, not like I want to be fancy, you know, I want
to be a fancy lady.
I want to be fancy, sexy, and cute.
Like, I want me elegant, classy.
Yeah.
The whole shebang.
Classy, elegant, fancy, sexy, and cute.
Like, I want it all.
I want it all.
She I won't be Sharpay, basically.
The triple threat.
I have my green does no bounds.
She does it up.
And then we're also playing around with like different
colors and everything.
So with all of that, let me, with all of that, we took both
concepts from my mama.
and Gina um and oh yeah and also my mama also tried
something with uh with a robe as well yes fancy robe pajamas
supremacist exactly exactly you know what's up I just want
it all wait where's my robe anyway um so my mom also uh got
try to think of something with the robe as well but I
thought it was too yellow you know just too much yellow I
want like a new color palette too um so those were um
everything from mama so we took all of that and then we let
Gina but we let Maddie uh figure um put all of those ideas
together um as you can see for almost first try but there's
like little things that was changed so like you know like
you know um so there's like little things i wanted dad to
have a little hat as well so uh so uh gina sorry uh manny um
almost first tried it with like taking everything all the
designs that we came up with like telling her like what i
liked about each design what i didn't like and take all the
stuff i liked and then combine it together and that's what
we got and it was almost like uh come on messy is my hero
nexi thank you super chat thank you thank you so um so
that's how we got the ultimate fusion and everything and i i
couldn't at first i couldn't pick between the light mode and
the dark mode so i had both just for any like you know for
any occasion if we need light mode or dark mode um and then
also i added i asked uh my mama for long hair as well uh i
wanted to have um i don't know I just I like having lots of
hair options so I also asked for long hair as well as the
short hair version they cover all the bases exactly so this
was like her I think this was her first draft and then from
here uh we gave dad a hat because I was like I want dad to
have a hat and then we gave dad a hat and then bam it was
done and then it was done so um so that's That's how we got
there.
Now, I had no plans on...
I was so busy with everything, like, you know, fantastic
reality with Doki Doki Rewind Time and also the special
announcement tomorrow and a lot of, like, work-related stuff
behind the scenes, which made me not able to really focus,
figure out what to do for the outfit reveal so on the last
week with two to three days inspiration struck me i was
inspired on what we could do to reveal the outfit so huge
shout out um let me put credits page um huge shout out uh to
Han Mika he be the asteroid music team um for uh for putting
up with me and coming up uh bringing my ideas to life within
two to three days so Han Mika if you guys didn't know who
Han Mika is also he be for the like literally like seven
hours before the reveal um because it was originally just
going to be the pokemon evolution and the digimon evolution
so the um and then when i figured oh i should have like a
little in pre-intro so i contacted heeby who is our
thumbnail person and also who creates emergency videos for
me whenever like i have last minute ideas so heeby helped me
make the uh the the move set thing you know where it's like
oh i leveled up And, oh, I gotta forget a move and
everything.
So, so Heavey made that video in less, in two to three
hours, seven hours before the outfit reveal.
Because I had inspiration of like, I don't know why.
I always get super creative.
Like, I have crazy creative ideas.
Literally, when it's T minus three to four days.
Like, that did not in my head.
Not in my head, three to four days, bam, I was like, oh my
god, what else did you evolve?
But I changed the lyrics and also Asteroid Music Team, they
literally made the instrumental, they made the instrumental
and like redid all the lyrics in just two days.
So if you guys didn't watch it, I love this video, it's so
funny.
I, like I had a step-by-step, like I wrote a detail thing of
like how, what I wanted for it.
I was like, change this lyric, change that lyric, and
everything.
And then add like the little things.
Because like, there were like real things, like, you know,
it's like, Dokiman, um, is, you did Dokibob to ultimate,
like, little thing.
And I was like, oh, in the beginning, uh, they say Digimon,
Digimon.
Can you add that in as well?
Cause it wasn't in there as first.
But I'll show it again.
I love it.
It's so funny.
I love
it.
I think it's so fucking funny i don't
it's like i was just like i was like sending time stamps and
everything like i wanted to be that just like this but like
you know they had like two days so like i didn't expect like
you know like one to one but the fact that they were able to
like make it like my the editors and also like the music
production very similar as i remember when as team asteroids
send me instrumental i was like okay can you add like the
the record scratches and the guitar riffs and everything
because like you know it's like the little things that make
it like like the digi did you evolve you know also why did
it start losing levels i don't know i fucking it was all in
japanese i did my best trying to recode it it was it was all
in japanese i spent two hours trying to recode and I gave
up.
I...
It wasn't...
I don't even know why it went backwards.
I just ran with it.
I just...
The show must go on.
No, it wasn't on purpose.
The show...
I know I'm so good at improv.
The show must go on.
Like...
It turned...
What was supposed to increase the level?
It's super chats, chatting, and also reacting.
It's all three.
I said I've turned all of them on, I think.
I coded it so everything will turn on.
So, because originally it was just for chatting, but you can
have reaction and also super chats to speed run it.
So I tried to turn all of it on because it would be really,
really slow.
It was just chats.
So I don't know.
I don't know if it actually sped run it.
I have no idea how it reversed, guys.
I am just as confused as you guys.
I just ran with it One thing is it could get the it could
get to 69 a lot faster, but it wouldn't let me control the
Difficulty because you can change the difficulty and I try
to but I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know anyway, let's watch it again
It's even funnier a third time, not gonna lie.
I'm gonna play it fourth time before I end.
I know, it's even funnier a third time.
It's so good.
I know.
It's made in two days.
It was made in two days.
Yes, that was my idea on the tomato as the friendship crest.
Because the editor was like, what do we want for the
friendship crest?
I was like, for the tomato.
Like, I don't know.
Like, I didn't have a lot of assets, you know.
At two days to like, two days, there's not a lot you could
do with that.
So I was just like, tomato.
Because it works.
works as a friendship crest.
Doki Man.
Doki Bird Monsters.
Atrus.
Mega Sleepy Doki Man.
Let it ride.
In doubt, just use a tomato.
Like, it always comes back to tomato.
Um.
Okay, yeah, anyway, let's go back.
Alright, so...
So huge shout-out to Han Mika.
Han Mika is also the one that made the girlfriend music
video, by the way.
They've made a lot of peek.
They've done the girlfriend.
They did Han solo.
And also this as well.
Good old reliable.
Oh, you might see Gina has done something other than the
design concepts.
So, oh yeah, I know some people need to go to sleep.
So I should actually...
Also, Sato, boy, gears for the thumbnail i love working with
voyagers where the outfit thumb outfit reveal thumbnails are
it's so cute but all right all right let me grab the
graphics real quick all right bam so it's on pre-orders
don't ask me when it's gonna come out i don't know i think
stuff going on so the pre-orders so there's gonna be regular
regular bundles and but then there's also 69 limited sign
checkies um so we have uh we have the like a basic acrylic
uh acrylic uh board i don't remember what it's called like
those like you know where there's the print and there's
acrylic board on it and everything there's a dad blanket
there's dragon slippers and the tomato boxers so you might
be wondering i showed this before but if you're new here you
get two pairs of boxers two for one so um there's a front
side and the back side depends on how you feel honestly like
it really depends on what you want to rock out it's what the
mood is you know So, you can have where the mouth is where
the pee-pee is, or the ass is where the mouth is.
It depends on how you feel that day.
Why is the mouth bigger in the back?
It's because you know why.
You know why.
so there's that we also have the epee blanket it's very soft
i actually i might i get to i got to touch it during anime
expo because our uh distributor brought it um brought it
over during anime expo it's very very soft um and it's very
comfy and everything um so it's designed by gina gina
herself um so yeah and then you have the little tomato at
the bottom too So shout out to Gina for designing the
blanket.
I love working with her.
She's very patient with me.
I'm so sorry Gina, I'm sorry you'll understand why I'm so
busy tomorrow you'll understand
Tomorrow everything will make sense
And then the other button thing you can get you can get all
these individually by the way You don't have to buy a bundle
and it went finally a little dragon slipper I'll show you
guys.
Okay, I'm going to show you One of the concept one of the
Samples you guys all know samples is not what it's going to
turn out in the end guys Just just remember that the sample
is different from the final just just remember Remember the
plushies guys remember the plushies But all right I need to
show you guys the sample for the slippers because We were
changing it gonna look a lot better this is what's the first
sample we got so that's why it's still the artwork because
um let me see i could find it uh because i wrote i wrote i
was like not happy with it and and uh with the sample and
they asked what's your feedback and i was like he looks like
he has
So, I was just like, um, we should fix that because he looks
like, looks like he has cancer on his head.
Like, I, we gotta figure out what to do with that.
So, you're like, it can't be that bad.
It can't be that bad.
oh yeah
so so i i was like please please fix it please fix this
because he looks like he looks like he has a tumor growing
on his head he's a unicorn So this is a sad.
This is just We're prototype.
This is a Prototype, guys.
We're Gonna fix it.
We're gonna fix it.
It's a prototype Don't worry I will make sure this This I
will make sure Crazy Koala Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Thank you.
It's perfect I will But the side, okay The side does not
look That I mean also he looks like he has A beer belly.
That too.
he looks like he has a beer belly and also like like the
side it doesn't look as bad but like when i look at it like
that like oh yeah that's a big cut so this is just it's a
prototype it's a prototype and we we will fix it
um don't fix this perfect unicorn dragon unlock unicorn go
man thank you with a super chat thank you thank you he's
thick and he has cancer all right anyway so and then this is
like um just like a little small thing it's a i think it's
called an acrylic board it's a little acrylic board there's
gonna be like um i think i'm sign i'll be not i'm not
signing it but it's gonna be a printed signature on there as
well as a little message i think i don't know if it was like
on or on this that will have a sign printer thing um so uh
oh and you think it was super chat thing there there's like
an acrylic panel oh yeah acrylic pad is right there an
acrylic panel and then also
um um um there is the epb checkie so if you buy the bundle
um it comes It comes with an alternative version of it.
So it comes with the winking version if you buy the bundle.
It doesn't matter if it's limited edition or the regular
bundle.
The bundle will include the alternative colors and
expression as well.
So it'll come in dark mode for your check-y.
All right.
I'm opening the store.
So give me a sec.
I need a login.
Let me log into the store.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
I'll do a countdown for you guys.
I'll do a little countdown.
You might have to have Doki merch preloaded.
I'll preload Doki merch right now too.
Alright.
My manager taught me how to do this because he's like, I'm
going to be sleeping.
Alright.
Four, three, two, one!
And the store is live!
Alright, here you guys go.
Good luck.
I just got the tracking number for my last order.
Time to buy more Toki merch.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck.
There's only 69.
But yes, if you guys don't have time to type what you want,
because, uh, we do have, uh, but yeah, good luck, everybody.
Ooh, there's a lot.
Alright, nice.
Alright, good luck, everyone, on getting the EP.
My PC died while trying to...
Wait, it's already sold out?
What the fuck?
no it's not I see it oh is it gone no
it's not I can still check out
I can still buy it oh never mind I it's gone and it's gone
that was like I got my thank you took you very excited for
next he think it was super thank you thank you uh gotcha one
let's a fucking go a solid thank you with a super chat thank
you thank you all right if you guys didn't write down like
um what you guys doki is distracted she won't know i'm
actually gay thank you super chat all right thank you thank
you thank you got mine to lfg allen thank you the super chat
thank you thank you um anyways i guys i would put more in if
my manager if my manager believed in me more.
My shorts, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got my checky.
My I had to bank my manager to even let me do to even let me
do like signed anything.
I was like, please.
I haven't done it in a year.
Please.
So So, yeah.
So, I didn't want to get yelled at and I managed to
negotiate for 69.
I managed to negotiate for 69 signed checkies.
Not just signed, but I will decorate it too.
I'll buy like this little day.
I don't do check, I don't do a lot of checkies, but I will
decorate them as well.
Also, let me give Dad a little treat real quick.
I'll be right back.
Anyway, I'm back.
Alright.
We still have the other stuff, though.
We still have the normal bundles and it will come with the
alternative expression and everything.
Let me...
Let's see.
Let me put the normal ones here.
I'm so mad to punch my card and I didn't get...
No!
You might have to...
Maybe you can bribe a dragon and...
Thank you for the Aka Super Quail.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Checked out.
Hope to see it soon.
I was rushing.
Can we add size options later?
Yeah, yes.
If you want to tell them what your size is, you can contact
the Doki merch account or send an email to send a support
ticket for having a wide range of merch size available.
Pleasantly surprised to find out there at the celebrities
that fit me.
Of course, Nexi.
a super chat thank you thank you um but yeah i always love
i'm glad to be able to do a lot of different um types of
merch um that's what i love about being able to uh being
able to like make merch and stuff is that i get to you know
experiment with merch um some will succeed and some will not
but at least i get to have fun with it get fun having like
different varieties of merch stuff that we can do um anyway
what else i want to talk about blah blah blah uh got my
lemon button also just got my dokey push and look so cute
thank you thank you for the super chat blazing thank you
thank you unfortunately now i know dog shirts do not work
it's not i'm just too ahead of my time oh yeah other than
that let me let me do the other website uh but if you guys
want to also match with me we still have the dokeybird eye
mask too wait where's my eye mask There.
Yeah!
If you want to match with me, you can still grab me.
Let's see.
Grab the eye match from Gina.
And she's also, if you're going to Off Kai, she's bringing
some of this stuff as well to Off Kai.
She's bringing a lot of Doki merch as well.
New EP merch out now.
there you go i know there's like you still get pajamas too
all right let me pin this new one there's other stuff too
but wait there's more oh so my chat is very slow right now
so i need to try to find my own comment so i can pin it but
wait there's more
sorry i know i know i've been wanting to have a ep uh an EP
outfit for so like a big dokey EP outfits for so long just
so I can be like fully disassociated and it'll be very
immersive also huge shout out to um um Athero for making the
low five BGM they made it in under a week so shout out to
them it's my starting scream song also shout out to no name
580 they made the they actually made I originally had
another artist doing the uh for the sleep api outfit slash
birthday merch but they had to um they had uh health issues
last minute but it was like two weeks it was two weeks
before I think it was like two almost less than two weeks
before the original reveal which was July 4th so no name and
was able to work on the checky, the checky and key visual
for us and actually send it to us at July 3rd.
And then after I told her, like, oh, we're going to be
rescheduling the reveal to, what day is it, to the 18th.
They edited a little bit more and also asked her if they
could make another wallpaper, make a free wallpaper for you
guys.
So they also drew a free wallpaper to commemorate uh the ep
outfit reveal oh yeah also another thing i wanted to tell
you guys um the hair will look a little bit different
because i'm getting that fixed soon because like i said i
procrastinated a little bit with checking uh checking with
celia for like edits and stuff or for the skin suit and uh
and i wanted to like get rid of the strand a little strand
that's hovering out right now So I'm getting rid of that
because I'm getting a little distracted.
So that will change later.
That's going to change whenever Celia has the time to edit
that a little bit.
It's my bangs.
You see that strand on my bangs there?
Right here?
For this side?
Yeah.
the not the the strand flowing out but it's like on my bangs
yeah i'm getting that cut off no not by the ear no no no no
no no i it's wait it's this one i'm getting that cut off
this is my this i'm getting a haircut last minute haircut
I'm getting distracted with it.
So I'm cutting it off.
This one.
This part.
Yeah.
I'm cutting that off.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
I can't unsee it now.
Good.
I didn't want to give you...
I didn't want to like...
Put any focus on it.
But like now I did.
But I'm getting a haircut later.
So I wanted to let you guys know ahead of time when you're
like, something's different.
I was like, y'all gone.
Oh man, I should have been like, do I, hey, do you know
what's different?
Like, I should have been like, I should have been like, hey
guys, what do you, you know what's different about me today?
You know, like when your girlfriend slash wife would be
like, Do you know anything different today?
And you're like, you're like, um, did you get new clothes?
Did you get a haircut?
And I'm like, no.
You never notice what I do.
That's a trap.
It's a trap.
She's trying to bait you.
So yeah.
Luckily, I didn't do that, guys.
I could have, like, next week, I could boot up the stream
and been like, Hey, dragons, you notice anything different?
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I did, but I didn't.
I told, I warned you guys ahead of time.
Okay, dokey, hear me out.
That necklace as a merch would go hard.
Trust Dracula's back me.
up thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that you
will that's true because i'm getting other stuff added or
fixed up i'm getting other stuff fixed up too uh whenever
she has the time and chow chiri as well and it'll be like
hey dragoons a spot the difference well minus one limit time
drop time to lay down that's right quail i have the superior
jokie well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um what else what else did i want to tell you guys oh yeah
uh oh yeah let me show you guys the wallpaper i know i
downloaded but i haven't i forgot to upload the wallpaper um
let me see where is this the fucking uh That's the word
called...
That's the word called...
Interrogation?
What is this, a fucking interrogation?
Why do you guys want to know what I'm going to change, huh?
It will be on the test next week.
Netpers, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
My bro Tuber has had insomnia so long, he's having nail
painting parties and asking of his hair change.
Insomnia induced paranoia, thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, by the way, since I'm EP, this fits more now.
It works with glasses, too, but for that,
it's more accurate to how I feel every day.
Um,
wait, I wanted to...
Oh, yeah, I keep forgetting.
I'm trying to show you guys the wallpaper.
Where did I download it?
Is it this?
No.
Is it... No.
Where did I download?
Did I... Yeah, I did.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no,
no, no, no.
All right.
I feel like it should be.
So this is the wallpaper.
It's from the same artist who did the, um, who did the, the
checky slash key visuals.
Okay.
There's also two alternative expressions too.
Where did it go?
Okay, there we go.
I, like, moved it too far up.
So...
Yay!
So this is wallpaper one.
They're both light mode, though.
It is wallpaper one.
And this is wallpaper two.
So it's, like, winky face.
So these are the free...
The free wallpapers for you guys.
I know it's so cute All right, let me upload this real fast
And then you can get your cameras ready Guys, and then you
can get the cameras ready I just need to Upload these and we
can start Taking pictures Like a photo shoot I'm gonna be at
We're gonna go to Paris Before the riot
All right, let's see Yeah I need to make like a full
wallpaper folder.
I have a wallpaper.
I have members' wallpaper, which by the way, we will get
back into members' wallpaper soon.
It's just, like I said, it's tomorrow you'll understand.
Like I said, tomorrow you'll understand.
Everything will make sense tomorrow.
All right, I put it in the birthday wallpapers.
It's soon trademarked.
So at least you can download the other wallpapers along the
way.
We haven't downloaded them yet.
So this is like from the last year's wallpaper folder.
Oh, silent.
I opened the store.
Are you proud of me?
You can't be like, are you sure you're able to?
I was like, I can do this.
I can open this.
check he sold out in less than 15 seconds we should add more
we should add a hundred more and make it 169 imagine that's
right i'm pressuring no that's right i'm calling him out in
public maybe he'll maybe he'll
He'll get peer pressured by the public.
Yeah, make you think of the prophets.
How about four?
What if it's 420?
It'll be so funny if it's 420.
What's the word called when you're, like, pressured by the
public?
Silent, are you peer pressured yet?
Maybe he'll succumb to the public.
damn for it okay that's a little too much to keep but
imagine a 420
but you're gonna have to sign 420 yeah but that's called
negotiation you try to you try you upsell so then when you
say okay but what about we meet in the middle and we meet in
the middle and we do one 169 and then he'll be like oh you
know what that's more reasonable we could do 169
i'm starting fire yeah i'm doing negotiating 101 the art of
the deal and here's the wallpapers
i can wait 20 29 yeah but And then if I have 30 more, the
number's not going to be as funny.
It's not going to be as funny if it's 30 more.
I need it to be a funny number.
So it's like, what's the point, you know?
What's the point of being in control of the inventory?
If I can't have it be a funny number.
Yeah, 30 dragoons must suffer for my whimsy.
I, look, I...
I'm artistic for my for my artistry all right that's the
link to the wallpapers by the way
guys I won't sacrifice my creativity it's 69 or no I said
169 but even even he won't he won't be he wants to come to
peer pressure
Photoshoot time.
Alright.
Shout out to Jesus.
I remember.
Jesus died for your sins.
Alright.
Let's do a...
Let's get to...
Where is it?
Bump.
Where's my green screen?
Let's go.
Jesus.
Guys, give me a second.
You have to find my green screen.
It's been a while.
Bum bum bum bum Don't worry any minute now Oh there you Yay
All right All right So this is normal We have the rope And
then also Hey Long hair yeah and then with roll on here oh
yeah with the purple work on us we're about to find out it's
uh technically it's magenta guys wait do we need another
color um what's the other color that i have i have green all
right do you think this green works or i also have this oh
this would work.
All right.
Sorry.
Flashbang.
Ha!
Guys, flashbang.
My eyes.
All right.
Maybe this green.
We could try.
The sacrifices you must make.
It's this or green.
Yeah, that's all.
The issue is that we have a lot of colors.
Light mode!
Ha!
All right.
Please go back to purple.
So, all right.
Are you guys ready?
I'm trying to remember what the combo was.
What's the combo again?
It's been a while.
It was...
Guys, what was the combo again?
Jesus!
Jesus, what is the combo?
Use blue?
I mean, this is a little bluish, though.
It's been a while.
I need Jesus to speak to me.
Oh my god, wait, someone's whistling outside.
Closing.
Oh, it's, okay.
Done.
The Jesus sacred text.
Okay.
Oh, it was was ibags was it ibags all right ready get
cameras ready in five four three two one done
i played i wasn't ready but done
Yeah, I was just like, what the fuck?
Who's whistling right now?
Didn't do the eye.
Wait, I'll be right back.
I'm going to close.
Let me close the line.
So there's no more whistling.
No longer are they allowed to whisper.
It's like whistle.
No longer.
We never heard from her again.
All right, all right, all right.
Let's see.
Different combinations.
I have so many combos.
So it's, like, hard to figure out what I want to do.
So, this is...
I think my favorite has to place it.
I think I love this part.
Oh, I love...
I don't know.
I love this pose.
I think it's so cute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, I think it's cute.
Oh, yeah, and with the glasses, too.
I think the glasses fit really well.
I think the glasses fit really, really well.
And then...
I'm so girly, I know!
I'm a woman!
Oh, my God!
It's crazy.
Oh!
Oh, yuck!
And also without the glass...
With the...
short hair too my little bow buns hair style
i love this oh my god i don't know there's just something
about i was playing around with this yesterday and there's
just something about this particular expression and pose i
don't know neurons activated you know it's just so cute i
say cute and sexy and i'm cute and Now, wait, wait, I can,
let me get immersive.
Hi guys, hello everyone.
Hey guys, I'm the dragons.
I think I'm cute right now.
You.
Who is this?
Turn back, turn back, turn back.
Neuron suddenly deactivated.
Stop that.
What did you do?
Because you're fancy and elegant until you open your mouth,
I'll give you a cue.
Thank you.
Let's see for chat.
Next.
Press B.
Rewind time.
awesome what about my deflated hair now you know now you see
why this is my favorite this is my favorite ctrl Z ctrl it's
not it was not that bad guys come on everyone's not that bad
all right let's see oh yeah and then I can do
it was that vennin oh wait i think it was like and
oh my god i could do so many different combos too um what
else can i do oh yeah the dark dark light the dark eye bags
i know there's so many things i can do unfortunately there's
no cat mode unfortunately not yet not yet that one is also
going to be fixed later that will be fixed at another time
and then there's dad yeah and dad here too dad with robe
with no robe with hat and and there's some eeping and and
there's some eeping even more Oh, and he can also Wait, not
only can he Eep here He can also Eep up here too All the
dads He can eat anywhere he wants All he does is Eep and
then We have, oh, and then you guys Right here There you
guys go Yeah, I was go.
And then we have...
Don't drop... Stop!
Stop swinging your head!
And don't drop him!
Um...
Yeah, we didn't do that.
And then...
I said, we have so many combos to play around with.
He's so jiggly.
I know.
He's like... He is like extra...
He's filled, like, 50% air.
Look at how squishy he is.
All the physics went to you, little buddy.
That's right.
Who's my physically, physically little boy?
He's so bouncy.
And then what else?
What else do you guys want?
Like I said, I have so many combinations now.
I don't know.
Oh, there's light mode.
Flashbang!
He's going to get sick.
He's just a toy.
I see.
And then the toy story comes out.
It comes like, I'm just a toy.
Hey, you guys have things?
You guys always had things.
Flashbang!
Christmas spirit.
Alright, what are you guys?
combos you guys want like i said we have so many what
else do you guys want oh yeah and then the controller here
it should work um i just don't want to i i don't want to
plug it in right now but uh we do have uh we do have like a
controller that we can bring out now yeah the dragon oh yeah
we can match too or the dragon slippers
Did I not do that already?
I feel like I did.
Yeah, the controller is working.
Let's see.
We have...
Uh...
I thought I did.
Glasses.
Yeah, there's...
There's me with glasses on.
Very simple glasses.
I think simplicity...
um just some plain old black glasses crying glasses long
hair no that is so it's like i'm taking a starbucks order
right now like would you like grande no cream or or cream
two percent milk or no percent or three percent milk all
right crying i'll do extra crying and uh long hair
yeah all right what name do you want to put it under
all right you think guys can I have some fortnite vbucks
guys did you use jokie bird code jokie bird in fortnite did
you No, no, no, guys, do you have, have you bought my dog
shirt?
Dockshirts are back!
Dockshirts are back on the store.
Guys, dockymerch.com is back, which means dog shirts are
back.
Guys, did you buy my dog shirts yet?
Did you?
I just can't add.
Guys, did you buy my dog shirts?
I have so many today, please, guys, guys, guys, get it
before.
where it's gone guys don't use the weaponized it's time it's
time with dog hey guys you know what's on the store right
now you should get it before it's all sold out and we're
before it's all it's sold out guys the dog shirts it's on
the store right now don't you don't you want to buy it
Because, um, don't you want to buy the dog shirts?
I'm sorry.
I'm weak to long-haired toky.
Thank you for the super chat.
And I was thinking, thank you.
This is what happens when you don't buy the...
But bag, bag.
If you buy five dog shirts, you can sew, you can cut the...
fabric and then sew it all together so it will fit your
husky or do you not care about me and my dog
shirts do you hate your dog do you hate your dog bag thank
you thank you wait hang on this is not illegal this is
illegal you're not allowed to be this cute on purpose thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you This is
manipulate.
Do you just hate your dog?
Do you hate your cat?
You know, dog shirts are interchangeable.
Your cat can wear the dog shirts.
In fact, it might as well be a pet shirt.
I don't need it.
Casey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We need to nerve her.
I am very meticulous.
They made her too strong.
I can...
I have unlocked...
I've unlocked...
A new power.
I've opened my third eye.
A new chakra has been unlocked.
With great power comes no responsibility.
She has got...
I've unlocked...
I've unlocked a potential.
sell more dog shirts.
Chikori, thank you for the five gift of shirts.
Chips, thank you, thank you.
She's too aware.
I realized what it's like.
I know how to sell shirts now.
No, no way.
Forget this.
I've learned a fifth move.
You can't weaponize your feminine charms.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, I've learned a fifth move.
Wait, so is it not made to pre-order like last time?
Sad.
No, no, God, my money on paycheck.
Don't come.
No, we did.
It is.
That was a limited edition one.
If you want the regular bundle, it's still open.
It's just a limited checky one is sold out.
But this is the, this is the made to order.
uh q says don't worry that one that one is still still you
can um still you can order or you can buy the individual
items if you just want the boxers why just i don't know i
think the boxers are neat i just think the boxers are neat
um all right any other any other combinations you want,
guys.
They are neat.
Also, the bundled the bundles, they come with alternative
art alternative art of the key visual.
So it's a different expression and it's dark mode.
Glasses, hand pose, and smirk with the long hair.
You guys love the glass.
glasses.
I do, too.
I like, I was like, neurons activated the moment I realized,
like, the glasses.
Surreally.
No, guys, no.
Bad.
You're not Jesus, rice.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I know.
It's so cute.
I think the glasses work really well with the PJ.
I told you guys!
Now you guys know what is my favorite outfit.
It's very versatile.
It did not.
Yeah.
I think I'll post it after the fix because actually I'll
post it for now.
I'll post the reference for now.
But I will post a newer version when we got the fixes that I
want.
Later.
Because I do want, I want like, I want like, you know, like
post sleepover where we did our nails together at the
slumber party.
Because I, you know, removed my nail polish for the slumber
party so we could decorate it together.
So the fix will have, I have a toggle where I can have like
nail polish on.
Because I think it'll be cuter, you know, with nail polish.
uh duck thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
white PJs long hair glasses okay white PJ what is this
vision you have
okay no hand i'm trying to figure out what it is i might not
be jesus but i'm the oj akasupa beggar plus glasses all
right dead eyes I know that I see the ice I I
I know it oh snap a cute cute elephant dokey the hair clips
are ah thank you thank you I wanted yeah I wanted to have
new hair clips because I, you know, I want new, I like new
accessory.
I know like some people like having like the same motifs and
everything.
So I wanted something like, you know, matching the nighttime
theme.
I know I, I saw what you did there.
But yeah, thank you for the super chat, DJ.
Thank you.
Next year.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll give you two seconds.
Two, two seconds.
all right ready in three two one
it's and it's done it's done all right i'll do two more i'll
take two more requests
two more requests and then and then we go back your cutest
today has been out to try wow they have a super chat I told
you guys this is my favorite outfit so far I said it would
be different I wanted to be wanted to be like more feminine
and you know what I don't know this is my favorite
I I
what else what else um can i get venti hazelnut mango dragon
fruit white chocolate mocha light water i didn't do uh are
you still going out with peter face they even super chat
patra said they can thank you yeah i could do that one
yeah i could do that one yeah that one i could do naturally
Danny, thank you, Super Chat, thank you.
Your favorite combo, please, for cosplay purposes.
Danny, you just missed it, Danny.
Jesus already requested that.
You got to rewind.
It was the first thing I did.
Don't worry, Jesus was there for you.
He died for your sins.
And then, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you.
Dad, plus dad, plus dad.
I don't know if I can do that.
Let's see.
Let's see if Dad is programmed to be...
Wait.
No, I can only have two dads.
what the fuck dokey they let you have two dads
oh my god they let you have two dads unfortunately only two
dads though yeah dad times two dad inception he's
multiplying Thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Unlimited dad glitch.
Unfortunately, only two dads, though.
We can't have a third dad, because we don't know how that
would work.
Let's see.
I'll go with this.
I think this would be my Difa.
Robe and hat.
I think this would be the Difa.
I don't know, long hair is really...
I like short.
My personal preference is the short hair, because I think
it's really...
It reminds me of Sailor Moon a little bit.
But, like, upside-down Sailor Moon.
Alright, that's all the requests.
I hope you're happy with the photo shoot, guys.
Let me go back to...
Sleepy Pajama.
Hello.
I'm back.
um But yeah, this is my favorite.
I'm glad you guys like this outfit too.
I said I'm sorry.
I do hope you guys like the reveal um Uh I know I didn't
have a lot prepared or anything, but Um, I do hope you guys
think the reveal was really fun You guys know what be you
know what's funnier a fourth time?
It
just keeps getting better.
Every time I listen to it, it just keeps getting better.
It just it just keeps getting better.
Don't keep Don't keep it are the champions.
I do this at least one more time.
I got a lot of mileage out of it.
I missed it.
Can you replay that?
The new stream is trying to play as my new intro right
after.
I get like a whole like an entire like cover done from just
them just I don't know yet I don't know how much I'm paying
for it because they haven't given me the bill yet because I
it was just I was just like get it done like I just like I
just need this I don't care money I mean they did this in
two days by the way video plus the the original cover from
them.
The instrumental is original.
Originally, it wasn't done by...
They remade the entire instrumental and also sang it with
the lyrics that I was like, can you sing it with...
Like, change these lyrics.
So instead of Digimon, do Dookimon.
Instead of Digivob, do Dookibob.
Character selected the Star Stream will be sick.
I love Digimon.
I love Digimon more than Pokemon.
I think everybody, well, I think everyone knows that.
One hour Doki Bird stream broken by random Doki Mon suck.
For those who don't know, Doki Mon.
Digimon is extremely popular in China and Hong Kong.
Like the only way to get any exclusive, like any nice
Digimon merch, you have to get it shipped from China.
Because they have all the good shit.
They have, like, they just love Digimon.
And who could playing them.
Digimon's awesome.
I love the Digimon designs.
Conco, thank you.
Superchat, thank you, thank you.
Whatever you have, the Dokiman vid auto-play.
Whenever someone sends a 200...
I couldn't do that.
And if someone sends $200 on Kasupa, I just automatically
plays the Dokiman sign.
They are the champions!
Jokiman.
Jokie Bird are the champions.
I love Rumble Arena.
I actually play at Rumble Arena growing up.
The sad thing is that Digimon, like my favorite Digimon
games were Digimon World and Rumble Arena.
But they have really bad games.
Digimon just has really bad games and really, really good
shows.
Well, the first...
First...
Three...
I almost said four.
Oh, shit.
I had to, like, remember what series four I was.
I was just, like, three.
Three.
That's true.
For those who didn't know, I don't know.
Three was weird just because like the children started
DigiVolving, you know?
Like it's not like there wasn't really any Digimon in three
because the children are Digimon and I don't know.
And I'm not like a very big JRPG person.
that's why I didn't um I never played the uh what was it one
of the time stranger ones yeah the child evolves into a man
and I was like oh I guess yeah that was four yeah I was just
like child evolves into a grown-ass man child evolves into a
big booba lady all right
All right, Keon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, I'm just like, all right.
Yeah, I was just like, so technically, that's just growing
up.
It was, I like Digimon more than, more than people evolving.
into I don't know I just I like Digimon more than uh people
evolving into Digimon I I just felt like people oh yeah and
then one of them evolves into a furry like uh a little furry
bear I was like all right all right growing up as evolving
yeah the little the little kid The tiny kid evolved into
a...
Yeah.
Evolved into a furry.
It's just like Animorphs.
That's true.
It's just Animorphs.
Yeah, I came to watch the digital monsters.
Not the people.
The humans are like the bonus stuff.
I want to know what the fuck Agumon's doing.
Like...
I want to see, I want to see Digimon evolving into like
giant mechas with 800 guns.
That's where I fuck with.
I want to see how many guns they can put on a Digimon.
It's called digital monsters, not digital people.
That's what the mom stands for.
Yes.
How many guns are they going to put on that Digimon?
Countrymon, my goat.
Metal Karuru Man.
Exactly.
That's where I fuck with for digital monsters.
I think Digimon is like the most American, American anime
ever.
In terms of like design wise.
Like, it's very, like the digital, the Digimon are very like
America.
You know?
It's because they got guns.
It's not just guns.
They literally have tank tank, man.
It's every weapon in existence.
Yeah, it's very American-coded.
I'm still sad that I missed out on...
that I missed out on watching the England game, the second
half.
I feel like I was robbed.
It's like either I have an outfit reveal or I watch the most
crazy game ever in the second half with you guys.
I still watched it though.
I still watched it, but you know, it would have been more
fun if I was doing a watch along with you guys.
It would have been more fucking crazy.
My content.
No!
My content!
I robbed myself.
That's true.
That's it.
Oh yeah, did you guys hear about...
Did you guys heard about the world's first robot MMA event
in China?
We're getting closer.
You know how there's like...
What's it called?
Death Battle with robots?
What is it called?
Uh...
Battlebot?
Yeah, you know Battlebot?
Fuck Battlebot.
We're going to China.
China, we have fucking robot MMA, bro.
Who cares about fucking...
Who cares about attaching a chainsaw on a robot?
We see robots fucking kicking each other.
like look at this that's crazy that's actually we're
actually getting closer to metabot guys like metabots i love
by the way i love metabot i wish metabot was more popular in
america because metabot was one of my favorite enemies too
growing up when they did like the english when they had the
english uh adaptation um in na in na that shit was fire.
I fucking loved MetaBot so much.
But I was so sad.
Never, like, apparently it was so popular.
It kept getting popular in Japan.
I don't know if it's still popular in Japan.
But, like, MetaBot just died after, like, the anime ended.
I still, like, loved MetaBot.
Because I know it was, like, super popular in Japan, still.
I wanted to buy the MetaBot figure.
They made, like, a poseable...
What was it?
I wanted to buy it so bad.
but um I think it was this one yeah I really wanted to buy
this when I was uh when it first came out when did this came
out this came out must have been years ago when this came
out I really wanted to buy it but at that time like I was a
kid I was a little kid Lord Croesus thank you Super Chat
thank you thank you Metabot was the go and we're getting
there soon we have MMA we have What is it called?
It's from Koto Obukia, Metabot.
It's such a pretty thing.
I remember when I saw it at Monkok.
What is this?
I loved all the designs.
Like, head...
Oh, and the cat one?
The cat one was cute, too.
Fuck the pink one.
That one was... She was useless.
Damn, this robot thing is real.
I thought it was AI.
They used controllers, but still...
I know!
That shit was crazy, Cloud.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I thought the pink one was useless.
Why is she there?
What's her...
Like, who invited her?
I watched robots to fucking beat each other up.
Why was she there?
All she did was just whenever a metabot...
Fucking, I guess she's a medic, but I don't, I don't, I
don't watch her to heal.
Not to be pink.
I watch robots.
I watch robots beat each other up.
No, he heals the robots.
You know what heals robots?
A fucking robot engineer?
A human being?
He'll fucking...
She's there for me.
okay but robot nurse though yeah you know what else can heal
a fucking mechanic like oh yeah also like do you guys hear
about like the streamer university that the irl streamers
normies are doing i was talking to this my talking to this
about to my friend he's like he's like sort of a normie and
he like watches he actually watches streamer university um i
don't normally i don't lot or very rarely um but I seen like
you know the clips that come up on my timeline and um I see
the clips a bit but like I was telling my friend and I was
like bro streamer university is literally just what a GTA RP
was IRL like I didn't think like that's what streamer
university is like Kai Sinat literally just made GTA RP, but
like in real life.
Like,
it feels like it.
All the fucking random clips I saw, it just felt like I'm
like a GTA RP session.
Yeah, and then like apparently Shaggy's there too.
Like some guy is role playing as like Scooby Doo and Shaggy
for Streamer University.
classes are very important i agree with him i think but but
i feel like i will say the difference though between this is
difference between vtubers and irl streamers slash uh other
content creators outside of vtubers i think for vtubers the
most money you can get um in terms of like what you earn is
through merch that's why you see a lot of vtubers doing
merch because for vtubers because like we're like mascots
we're we're like us ourselves is the brand and i will say
for us for vtubers themselves uh we make more from merch
than anything else compared to like sponsors or streaming or
anything that's why you see a lot of merch from vtubers yeah
and like uh um for irl streaming yeah it's like Sanrio
that's why like you see like youtuber companies as well they
they push a lot of merch and stuff like a lot of acrylic
stands and like buttons and everything and um because like
the profit margin that's why you see a lot of acrylic stands
because like fan culture you know like Oshi culture because
like it's like high profits for low um what's the word it's
like low cost but high profits because acrylic stands are
very easy to make and stuff so that's why you see a lot of
acrylic stands and stuff being pushed out because they're
very simple to make
yeah high margins yeah
like irl streamers yeah return investment um but i i like i
could easily just do acrylic stands but i'd like because you
know how like a lot of anime shows a lot of like
collaborations like you can even see like a lot of shows
that are shows and games that are popular in japan you
Digital Circus and Digital Circus and what's the other one?
Has been Hotel.
When they do collaboration in Japan, they always do, they
always push out like acrylic stands, buttons, folders, stuff
like that.
Because it's like, that's what's popular in Japan and that's
what's also like makes a lot of money via merch.
Because you see, like, we guys didn't know.
The company behind Digital Circus, um what are they called
again um i forgot their name the studio's name but a lot of
their shows are funded through merch sales because merch for
them because like you know like their shows are their brands
um glitch yeah glitch studio they always say like like the
show is funded via merch because that's where most of their
that's where the money comes from um
yeah it's easy to make and people like them that's why i
also like you know I try not to spam like acrylic stands and
stuff like like acrylic stuff but uh but and I do like to
like experiment with like merch that I want to make um
because I want you know I guess I want to have fun yeah but
you can tell like in Japan when they do like cafe collabs
cafe collabs or like collaborations with other brands or
other um other job like other shows or other games usually
like um usually what they do is like buttons stickers
acrylic stands um rubber stamps stuff like that because
they're all like uh the roi is like high and um and people
love collecting them
um yeah and checkies too yeah checkies as well that's like
that's why like but then that's why like i think that's the
difference between vtubers and like irl streamers or like
streamers of different commute genres because like they're
like saying they make very little from merch but like if you
but for vtubers majority of vtubers make the most money
through merch i
mean but also but also it really depends on who's sponsoring
you too so if fucking Nike sponsoring you then yeah like you
know that that would make sense I don't think yeah if so I
but that's also like I think that's also like the downsides
as well like the pros and cons of of our of streamers versus
VTubers because we're VTubers we can't do product placements
so you know how like IRL streamers they would have like the
fucking Red Bull fridge behind them because they pay for
that um so like you get paid for having like you know a Red
Bull fridge behind you because it's always visible on your
screen on your webcam so like that's a lot of money as well
like YouTubers can't really do that we could do a virtual
fridge but it's not the same I've actually I remember I
remember pitching that before being like but then they're
like I rather have the real fridge like Yeah, you know,
they're like, yeah, it's not the same, you know?
Because you can have the real fridge behind you at all
times, too, you know?
Because, you know, if I'm streaming, I'm just there, you
know, I can't have a fucking fridge behind me when I'm
playing a game.
But for IRL streamers, it's the cam, so you can always see
their room behind them.
But when I'm streaming, I'm fucking, I'm in the void.
I'm
Guys, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you Um I
mean, I wouldn't want a picture of Doug Doug on my desk But
a smile and Doki on the other hand So Aromouch is very,
yeah, it's different to market Guys, thank you, the super
chat, thank you, thank you Uh, yeah, there's no fridge Yeah
Um So it really depends on It's like, it depends, because
that's the difference product placements very easily with
our RL streamers.
We can't really do it for VTubers.
That's why, like, for VTubers, we make more off of merch
versus sponsors.
It's, like, for sponsors, we could do, like, but we also
have conventions, too.
We have conventions.
Because I know, like, for streamers, RL streamers, they
usually do TwitchCon, and that's really it.
But for VTubers, we're, since we're, like, in the anime
community, we can do conventions as well.
meet and greets um um yeah so there is other stuff so it's
just it's like difference between it was very interesting
though whoops it was very interesting video or clip
race car style i saw like some vtubers they have like
outfits made um for their sponsor content and stuff i
thought that was really cool um a nice way to do sponsored
content Oh my god, this is actually a Good Night Dragoons in
disguise.
Wait a minute, Doki.
This is just Good Night Dragoons.
Now you know.
It really is.
It's been 84 years.
It's a tired time.
It's just good night dragons.
Always.
The two for one special.
The outfit was just a bonus.
It's the merch.
I think it's like whatever is left after that.
It's gone.
I know she's bringing some over to.
Because it's like the remaining stock.
That's left.
so whatever she's bringing some to off tie so she's bringing
a lot let me show you guys this is the least i could do for
gina because she's done so much for me and also a way to say
sorry because i also stress her out a lot i don't know she's
here but i i stress her out a lot too
It's like Yeah And she had a catalog Posted All right Here
are the Gina Gina stuff at Offkai Although I'm not a guest
at Offkai I might have something at Offkai So you're going
to Offkai Uh If you're going to off-cut, make sure to go
grab some Doki merch.
Alright.
Where's all the Doki stuff?
It's literally all Doki!
Okay, it's almost all Doki's.
It's Doki and Friends!
And also, she has a little...
I didn't know she did this, too.
I was like, oh my god, it's so cute.
So there's like the keychains.
There's a coin pouch.
There's a sticker sheet.
There's a free fan.
And it looks like I'm like...
there's a ruler oh my god i need to get this luggage tag
because i you know ever since i lost the other luggage tag i
might as well there's that dope kitty in the area luggage
tag there's the shirt there with the doki verse which doki
verse into the doki verse we go i love that okay i love all
the memes from the odyssey where there was one where um it
was like uh wait i remember i sent it to somebody actually I
don't even know if I said let's see I love the all the
Odyssey memes I think they're so funny Athena and talent
matches will return in spider-man brand new day I don't if
anyone knows it's basically Zendaya and Tom Holland in
Odyssey and they're like oh my god they're gonna come back
in spider-man I thought that was so fucking funny the
Odyssey memes are or spy
yeah but yeah please feel if you're going to off guy support
gina she has a lot of dokey stuff like just buy everything
make sure she sells out and then there's like and then you
can get picture too you can get picture with all the dokey
stands and everything is so cute if you're there good
morning that new i know it's so cute juge good morning to
you too Bring the mini-dokies.
Guys, bring the mini-dokies to let us down and take a
picture with it, too.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, yeah, for those who are new here, let me show you guys
some combos.
So there's the long hair.
And then...
I just think this is cute.
It's so cute.
I think it'll be cute with nail polish though so i'm excited
to um i'm excited to like uh add nail polish later yeah this
is my favorite pose i think i'm just do black black or blue
honestly and i think that would work the most the best black
or blue
like uh like the dark purple sorry dark purple dark purple
not like blue blue but like dark purple or black black is
like just a classic but you can't go wrong with black you
know
like the same as the outfit i'm wearing right now light moon
Lightboat!
Yeah.
Black is a classic.
I'm choosing the...
Yeah, but I want to have a fix soon-ish, you know?
I don't want to start it too long, so I can post like an
updated version of it.
Flashbang!
Oh, yeah, guys, wait, wait, I figured it out.
Wait, I found, guys, I found it.
Wait, actually, can I?
Let me see.
Did I buy it?
Guys, I found it, guys.
Remember what I said I wanted to do?
A Super Chat Endurance Stream?
Guys, I found it.
It's from the same program.
Wait, let me see if I bought it.
I don't know if I bought it.
Did I buy it?
No.
Um.
I followed.
I have.
I bookmarked it.
Wait, let me say I can test it out.
It's so funny.
I don't want to bump bump bump.
Oh, wait.
Let me.
Uh.
Sorry.
I just had to.
Work message real quick.
I'm going to order it.
I'm going to show you guys.
This is like a little preview.
I need to buy it though
Let me see.
Let me see if I buy it
Just to
All right, sorry I I had to do a work message real quick All
right, let me buy this and I'll give you a preview now that
I finally realize how to set up this Japanese program I
don't think I need to know how to I might have to learn how
to recode this because it's all in Japanese and also in yen
so like um so we're gonna figure this out why is there too
fat okay there we go but we'll pretend it's in yen for now
because I can't be bothered to learn how to recode this I
really cannot be there you go it's called one com so one com
is like the japanese equivalent to streamer bot slash stream
labs slash uh ytf uh and it's it's very um it's it's really
cool uh and basically they can convert all the codes to
different uh streaming platforms so it the codes can work
for like any platforms basically like twitch and youtube
they'll convert it for you and like i finally figured out
how to use it
like this finally after years i figured it out all right
let's see if i know how to do this
oh i'm in admin mode all right what browser source okay
Okay, let me...
Okay, let me see.
BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM.
BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM.
All right, it should be this local file.
Uh...
Is it this?
Should be this.
Where's the fuck?
Wait.
Am I looking at this correctly?
Or is it this?
No, it's this.
Sorry, I'm trying to figure out how to show this.
Uh...
Oh, yeah, okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
It's on so many super chats!
So many super chats!
Wow!
Oh, thank you everyone for the super chats, yes!
Oh, thank you!
It's a rainbow!
It's...
Wow!
Oh, thank you, everyone!
For the rainbow soupas!
Oh, my God.
You guys are so kind.
Yeah.
Yes.
You guys are so nice.
Yeah.
Did you guys know Super Chess are free right now?
We're all rainbows.
Wait, I can make this even better, guys.
Watch this.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
catching up right now.
You guys don't see it yet, but don't worry.
Oh my god, even Nightbot super chatted me!
Oh!
Yes!
Oh, that's crazy!
Even Nightbot super chatted me!
Thank you so much!
Oh!
Oh, thank you, Nightbot!
Thank you!
I'm free.
That's crazy.
I don't deserve this.
Oh.
So that's what I was talking about earlier.
This is what I was talking about.
But I didn't figure out how to make this.
No, I'll keep donating this.
stream never and i pause you've seen oh my god you know
what's crazy it's it's sort of behind right now uh how much
yen is to keep making so right now um what's going on in
what you see right now is a little behind from from what
from what it is on my screen.
And the soup is free.
My Oshi is so fucking wealthy.
Where did all this money get to keep my country's entire
GDP?
It's trying to catch up right now.
It's, um, yeah, it's...
the way for the real time it's at 13 it's at 1300 13,900
we're at 448 on the screen but like on it's so rendering
we're making it rain we really are it's going fucking crazy
right now okay wait I might have to reset let me reset it
Yeah, oh shit.
I went back to the beginning.
We're in rewind time No, I went too far All right It's
raining cash
Thanks for the I I accidentally gave it a refunded
everybody.
It's okay.
You can re give me the money guys guys my bad I accidentally
refunded everything the tax man arrived but anyway so that's
the fun thing I found out I found out it was this pro I
found out it was on this program so a little bit of a sneak
peek of what we are going to do in the future what I I just
need to figure out how to recode it so that it's not in yen.
Did someone say free Supa?
Thank you, with Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Robin, thank you with a Super Chat.
Super duper.
Uh, Toki, thank you for the...
Yeah, I refunded everyone so you guys can reset me the money
again.
I know, I know, I'm so good.
Just so all of you guys can resend me the money.
Guys, don't worry.
Do not worry.
I'm here for you guys.
And so many supers.
I confess that I got my wallet stolen.
But cute as fuck Biffoot while drunk in the mountains now.
No one will know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Black Knight.
You know, super chat.
Thank you.
a duck thank you the super chat thank you thank you since
you're making some additional changes to outfit can you have
the left strap fall off right the right one uh pretty
pleasing jagu on top no you only get the left shoulder thank
you with the super chat thank you thank you um burla uh
burla thank you for the super chat thank you thank you don't
get to ask more money the entire nation of argentina thank
you for the super chat it's still going it hasn't stopped
yet guys and it's still going
so much super chats all right i'm gonna call here guys uh
thank you all for hanging out with me today um thank you all
for coming to the outfit debut i think i got everything I
wanted to talk about let me double check real quick um let
me double check if I got everything oh yes tomorrow tomorrow
do not forget tomorrow I'm gonna make the waiting room but
tomorrow we have a special announcement uh with Iron Mouse
uh Rin and Amalie so make sure you check it out tomorrow
tomorrow I will be streaming tomorrow so yes tomorrow there
is a to be there because we are announcing something very
very very special and also one of reasons why i was so
fucking busy um the last couple of months thank you super
chat many thank you thank you uh since we're talking about
minor alterations i have a that's on your payroll not mine
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um so oh
shit there's two streams sorry and tomorrow we're watching
the finals we're watching the files and then doing the
announcement that we're also watching the finals for world
cup tomorrow um but before i go i'll do a little shout to uh
where is it um show the credits page again uh a huge thank
you to everybody that worked on uh that worked on the Uh,
the outfit reveal, uh, shout out to Silia Cho, uh, no name,
Arthuro, Kamame, Wini, uh, Gina, Foya Gears, Asteroid Music
King, and Hemi, and Han Mika, thank you to them for all the
hard work in making this outfit debut.
I know it's, like, not super elaborate or anything, but I
still hope you guys had fun with the debut.
I always like to try to do something fun.
for you guys not just like you know you know i almost did a
shadow drop guys i i did almost do it just went bam outfit
but um what i love about doing outfit reveals is that i get
to be a little bit creative with them um so um i hope you
guys have fun with the little chip posts i do when it comes
to outfit debuts and a little bit of like some creative fun
times um to just reveal the outfit and uh and yeah i just
hope you guys like my new new skin suit guys you know what
will be funnier a fifth time i wonder what would be even
funnier a fifth time
Don't you bear monsters, don't you buy my other champions?
Eepie!
Don't you buy me!
Don't you buy me?